And less gay boom.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're live.
Alonzo Bowden.
How are you man?
What is up,
Joe?
I'm grateful and somber times.
These are the weirdest fucking times
ever.
Rip to Tom Petty A.
I guess we have to say that too,
obviously
this time.
And,
and like everyone's been saying again,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
here we go again.
Another go again,
another mass shooting.
And the,
the.
I think the most disturbing graphic to
me was the scorecard.
Like they showed like this guy got 58
and then the guy in Orlando got what?
40 something.
And so because it's like,
okay,
you just encouraged the next cycle to
try to set the record.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like,
it shouldn't be.
There has to be another way to say it
without giving publicity to he killed
more than anybody else.
Yeah.
Know.
Well,
for everybody's listening in the future,
this is taking place.
We're recording this on Tuesday.
Uh,
the massacre happened in Las Vegas on
Sunday,
so it's just a couple of days ago and we
were just going over all the details of
it.
I'm,
I'm reading online here,
he killed 59 people injured,
527,
which is just fucking completely insane.
I mean 527 people shot.
Is that right?
Or is that like,
does that count?
People trampled?
I think it,
it includes people trample them injured
otherwise,
but there were a hell of a lot of people
shot.
I mean he opened up with automatic
weapons into a crowd of thousands of
people to where probably,
you know,
did any bullets hit the ground?
Like there were so many people if this
thing that every bullet probably hit
somebody.
Yeah.
You know,
probably or more than one person
dependent.
I don't know the power of the ballistics
of the weapon,
but.
Oh yeah,
he definitely,
like bullets could have went through one
guy in Texas.
I'm sure they did.
I'm 100 percent.
This guy,
first of all,
there's a,
you know,
everybody's a,
becomes a big gun control argument,
which it should be right?
But uh,
one thing that we got to really take
into considerations,
he had an illegal guns.
These guns were illegal I think for 25
years.
So this isn't,
I don't know how much of this could have
been helped by making it more illegal.
Yeah.
It,
you know,
that's always a debate first.
The first problem is what was going on
yesterday when they say this is not the
time to talk about guns.
Of course it is.
And it did.
Yeah,
of course it's the exact time to talk
about guns and,
and,
and I'm not a gun guy in the sense that
I'm not a gun owner,
but I get it with guys who are into
guns.
I always compare it to my love of cars
and bikes or anything mechanical or
whatever.
I understand it but,
but the people,
most of the people I talked to who loved
guns don't have a problem with like
registration certainly don't have a
problem with education and,
and what I call common sense gun
ownership and that there is some guns
that I get it.
You want,
there are some guns that you know,
and again,
I'm not speaking with any expertise,
but from the layman's point of view,
it's like,
why do you need the semiautomatic
military style weapon in,
in,
uh,
you know,
don't tell me you have it for hunting or
anything else.
Like if there's a reason you want to
collect it,
just like if there's a reason you want
to own a race car,
right?
And somebody says,
why do you need a car that does 200
miles an hour?
Well,
you may have a reason you want that race
car,
but you don't use it on the street.
You can't take it out onto the streets.
And I.
and I think that should be that there
should be some kind of rule with that
kind of weapon that if.
Here's the thing,
it doesn't matter if there's a rule.
This guy,
there were plenty of rules.
Yeah,
that guy violated all the rules that
this guy did.
But I'm just talking about the general
attitude towards sales.
Just the idea that you can walk into a
store and buy these weapons.
It should somehow be more difficult to,
you know,
and again this is my opinion,
right,
but I think it should be more difficult
to buy a weapon of that tight.
Yeah.
Well these are all illegal weapons.
This guy,
this guy shot,
converted them to fully automatic and
fully automatics illegal everywhere.
Right.
Here's what's fucked up about this guy.
This guy didn't have a criminal record.
He had no army training,
no religious or political affiliation
affiliations.
No one has any idea what his motives
were.
He was wealthy.
He's a big time high roller,
which is how he got this giant suite in
Vegas.
I mean,
it is fucking bizarre.
Did you see his brother get interviewed?
Yeah.
And,
and it,
it's.
Well,
it's,
that's the thing about this,
that's the thing about this kind of
insanity,
right?
There is usually no outward like that.
Like how many people are like this in
this country that we don't know about?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
That have as,
and particularly if you're wealthy,
if you're wealthy,
it's so much easier to hide it,
right?
Because you may have a big house,
you may have a compound,
you may have a,
you know,
a camp,
a place you go camping in the woods,
units actually stocked with,
you know,
a 100 weapons or something like that.
I mean that the randomness of this,
to me that is the biggest horror.
The worst thing about this to me is just
the idea.
Like you went to a fucking concert,
right?
Like that's all you did.
You went to a concert in Vegas and
you're never coming home.
Your family's destroyed everything.
And I mean,
and,
and that is the utter randomness of it
that you can't control.
Well,
that's what's terrifying about it.
This,
which is really strange to me,
the definition of terrorist.
Nobody's calling this guy a terrorist.
Like what?
Do you have to be like,
political or religious to be a
terrorist?
Like how the fuck this guy.
Not a terribly.
Yes,
this is definitely terror.
This is definitely terror because you
know why it's terrible because now are
you going to go to a big event in Vegas?
Are you going to go to a big outdoor
con?
You know,
Vegas does these music festivals in
front of these towers and if someone
could do something like this and the
end,
the pools,
you know,
they have those giant Edm parties at the
pool all summer that are literally
surrounded by the Tower of whatever
hotel you're in so next.
So that's why it's terror because now
you have to be afraid to do that.
Well,
not only that,
like this,
now they're going to have some sort of
screening when you go into hotels,
which by the way,
why the fuck didn't they have them
already?
How I've always thought this.
The airports are so stringent,
like you go through the airports,
they check your Dick.
They literally will pat your Dick if you
hit a random,
you know,
being.
I'm sorry sir,
we got to check your day,
your random.
And they literally put the back of their
hand because it was really odd to me
that it's okay to touch your Dick with
the back of your back.
The less sensitive they get to smooth it
down.
No,
that's so weird.
Like it's okay sir.
I'm just using the back of my hand to
touch your Dick like we might have had.
They might've had them grabbing and some
guy was just like,
I'm not grabbing a hard dick.
There's no doubt it was them.
They got the union,
the other guy,
like I'm not getting my dick hard by
some guy who's looking for a weapon.
It's just weird that they can do that.
But if you go through the airport,
right,
like airports we've decided are places
where terror exists,
right?
So you have like,
like I have Tsa Pre med,
I have a,
um,
a global entry and all of that have a
clear,
clear is the best.
Queer is the best way.
Of course.
Yeah.
What a habit.
You just put your fingers down.
Bam.
It's got a picture of you go right
through.
It takes two seconds,
right?
Yeah.
But that's just a place where we've
decided you have terror.
Right.
And now are we going to decide that you
have terror everywhere?
No,
I don't think so.
I mean,
for one thing,
I,
I'm,
I'm not buying into the hotel argument.
Like there's a bigger issue here than
the hotels and,
and the issue is the weapons and what
can we do about the proliferation?
Proliferation of weapons proliferation.
Proliferation of weapons.
Yeah.
Sorry about that.
You started.
Where did you go?
Oh,
I'm too deep into this word.
I got too deep into a word now.
There's no backing out all the damn
weapons.
No,
but that.
But that's the issue.
The thing about hotels though,
and this been in the United States,
the privacy issue is huge,
right?
Your hotel room is basically your home
away from home.
When do you get what other privacy rules
of checking what you bring into a hotel.
What's in your hotel room room?
I remember the um,
the stoplight cameras,
right?
Yes.
And they got sued and people got in
trouble because they got that picture
taken and the wrong person was in their
car.
Right?
So it's.
That chick wasn't,
his wife dies.
Yeah.
Or this guy wasn't his husband.
One guy sued because he,
the picture was taken.
The woman wasn't his.
They send the ticket
to your house,
right?
He got into A.
Yeah,
exactly.
And,
and he won the suit in the sense that
you're,
there's a level of privacy that's
expected in your cost.
Do you understand why that it's illegal
though,
because it's a third party.
It's not actually.
Even the government,
they farmed it off.
They say on some other company that's
sending you a ticket and charging you
money.
Right.
And everybody was like,
well,
what do you guys are having your hiring
people to do this commissioning a place
to write tickets,
which they had to do.
They had to rename the cameras to only
hit the license plate.
But that's not true because I got one
the other day you got showed you sent me
a picture of me smiling.
Well it's not little cocky.
Tried to go right on red flashed me.
But.
But the point being in your hotel room,
like there's an expectation of privacy
and and where is that line drawn?
The other big difference to be drawn in
Vegas because people get freaky in
Vegas.
Yeah.
Right.
The other big difference,
and I'll tell you a vegas story about
that.
That's great.
I heard.
But the other big differences when
you're on an airplane,
your trapped in that airplane when
you're in a hotel like you can run,
you know what I mean?
You can order it on down the stairs.
You can,
you really know you,
you compared to being in an airplane.
But I think it's a valid comparison
honestly.
I mean it's like you're still in a box,
you're in it,
you're in a confined space.
But I think it's easier to escape.
Now the thing about about Vegas,
this guy told me who was a security guy,
he said the thing about the cameras is
you,
you see who's with who?
And then there was one particular guy
that kept singing but he kept bringing
transgender hookers to his room and like
they knew who he was.
He was like a famous guy and they were
like,
yeah,
we can,
we could destroy this guy if we wanted.
We got.
Because they got cameras everywhere in
Vegas,
right?
They know who's coming upstairs room.
They know what room they're going to
get.
Like super obvious transgender ones
like,
yeah,
like the giant football player you guys
felt like you dresses on.
So,
uh,
you know,
so I had to give up that hobby.
No,
I'm kidding.
That's the only thing from this podcast
that's going to go out viral.
We knew it.
Well.
Here's another thing that is a giant
issue that,
uh,
haven't heard discussed at all.
Mental health.
And this is really what this is all
about.
This is,
I mean this is a gun issue in the sense
that he used guns,
but then is it a truck issue in Nice
France where that guy just drove into
those people?
I mean,
is it a.
there's a ton of different ways to kill
people and I'm sure we're going to see
more of these fucked up ways in the
future,
but the real issue is a mental health
issue.
Now this guy,
his dad was a psychopath.
He was a serial bank robber.
He spent eight years on the FBI's most
wanted list.
Here's the question,
right?
Like is that genetic?
Like does that transfer over?
Like how does that work?
It
could be genetic,
it could be that psychological thing of
I want to outdo my dad,
this,
this guy could be.
I mean,
no,
this guy's a millionaire.
Right.
And so on.
Like,
so he,
he's obviously a high achiever,
but he could have that whole,
I'm not kidding.
You could have that hole where he always
wanted to do something bigger than his
dad or he wanted some approval,
you know what I mean?
Some weird kind of approval thing.
Yeah,
I guess that's just speculation,
right,
man?
Yeah.
I mean you could speculate a,
you know,
a bunch our mental health issue,
just a health issue in this country that
that's a show unto itself,
right?
We don't,
we don't take care of ourselves.
We don't take care of people.
We don't provide for the mental health,
the mental health problem.
You look downtown in any city in
America,
wandering the streets,
homeless.
You got schizophrenia and,
and all kinds of people and you know,
God forbid they got weapons,
you know,
who knows,
like you talk about the other ways.
I'm sure there are attacks that we just
don't hear about.
You know where some guy goes nuts with a
knife or a broken bottle and whatever
else,
man,
that's one of the big things that
happens in places that have stricter gun
control and the argument would be that,
hey,
you know,
that's safer for the people.
It's easier to handle.
There's more things that you can do.
Some guy with a machine gun going down
all these people.
But again,
gun control's not really gonna help
this,
this guy was using illegal guns.
I mean the issue at this point is that
there's so many guns out there,
like even if you made guns illegal,
what are we going to sweep?
Are we going to go house to house?
And if we do sweep and go house to
house,
man,
people are going to resist that because
for every one of these psychopaths that
winds up shooting people and,
and,
and gunning someone down,
there's going to be genuine normal
people that want a gun to protect their
family.
Maybe they live in a sketchy
neighborhood and then all of a sudden
the government comes along and says,
well,
now it's illegal for you to possess that
gun.
Well then who has guns?
Well,
we're already criminals.
See,
I think the solution is in between and I
think this is another one where we get,
you know,
this is a problem we have and I can't
even say when it started,
when you have the two sides and it's
either or so either you know,
no gun regulations or,
or far too many gun regulations and I
think the solution is somewhere in
between,
in my opinion.
It's always been like why can't we treat
them like cars.
Like when you buy a car,
you registered the car,
right?
So the government knows like Joe knows
Joe has this car,
right?
And then when you,
you have to have insurance in case
something goes wrong with the car and
you hurt somebody and then if you sell
the car to me,
you tell the government,
hey,
I just sold the car to Alonzo.
I'm no longer liable for this car,
Alonzo's liable for this car.
And I go,
I've always thought that would be the
level of common sense gun registration.
Well here's another one.
Okay.
Along with that,
with guns,
you don't really have to know how to use
them
is where they really fucked up things
about.
Unfortunately
if you drive a car,
you have to take tests,
you have to pass,
you have to understand the registration,
the rules rather.
I mean you have to,
you have to go and a guy has a sit next
to you,
you have to go through a driver's test
and I don't see why we can't do that
with guns.
You should absolutely.
You have to go to a range and show,
you know,
like the safety of using a gun and,
and how to shoot it.
You know,
I don't,
I don't see why we can't do that.
And even if your family teaches you,
right,
they say like in a lot of places you
grow up with guns and as a kid your dad
teaches you.
Well,
if your dad teaches you to drive,
you still have to go to DMV and take the
test.
So it's like your dad,
your mom,
whoever your uncle could teach you to
shoot,
but you still,
there should be some,
some level of testing to,
to get an idea because we have,
you know,
just a couple of weeks ago where you had
a four year old in Florida who was
looking in their grandmother's purse for
candy and shot themselves and it's like
that grandma,
there's a safety issue with the gun.
Like you don't tell the kid to go get
some candy when you know you have a gun.
I think there's a nutty number,
like 21 people a year killed in this
country by arm.
Toddlers.
Yeah.
I believe it.
Find out what the number is.
I think it's 21.
People were shot to death by babies.
Yeah.
Any of the other thing is.
And you brought it up like how okay,
if we didn't have guns then they'd be
killing,
you know,
with knives or clubs or something like,
just that idea that,
that we have to have that discussion
like,
well,
what weapon or the mass killer is going
to use?
That in itself is insane.
Just the fact that we're like,
yeah,
we're going to have these mass killers.
We,
we gotta have them working with
different weapons.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't know on the mental health I,
I'm,
I'm not even going to pretend to have
the expertise to talk about what it is,
but it's an issue that we don't spend
money on.
It's an issue not covered by a lot of
insurance.
A lot of insurance doesn't cover any
kind of mental health care.
Here's the thing,
even if it does cover mean a giant
percentage of the people that commit
these giant mass shootings are either on
psychoactive medication or are having
withdrawals from psychoactive
medication.
So even if your insurance covers it,
even if you're medicated by a doctor,
there's like,
there's a disassociative quality
apparently with a lot of these
antidepressants and anti psychotic
medications that people take that with
the right combination of biology,
circumstances,
genetics,
whatever it is.
People just can snap and they don't have
an issue.
I mean,
what,
what are the numbers of people that are
on that stuff?
A giant number.
What are the numbers of people that
actually wind up and go and do
shootings?
Much,
much,
much smaller number,
but it's enough that if it happens once
a year like Orlando last year and then
this year in Vegas,
I mean,
what the Fuck Nigga again,
we don't know why this guy did this.
We have no idea if he was on anything,
but what the fuck is
it that we have to do to stop this stuff
from happening?
Well,
I mean,
I'm sure there were scientists who study
it and all,
but I can't imagine people that can do,
can predict it.
People are getting shot by toddlers on a
weekly basis this year.
Trust Jesus Christ.
How many people have killed themselves?
18 more injured themselves.
10 injured other people to killed other
people.
That was in 2015
last year.
Toddlers have killed at least shot at
least 23 people this year.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Five months.
Oh my God.
Okay,
so we can't,
we cannot match that with no argument of
toddler drivers having run over.
People know.
Well irresponsible gun owners.
That is.
And,
and again,
that gets back to what you're saying,
the education,
like learn to own a gun safely to keep
it somewhere where a toddlers not going
to get to it.
Something.
Everything dangerous safely,
you know,
everything.
And isn't it funny how you,
you know,
we do kid proof a house,
like,
you know,
they have some plastic things that go
into the electrical sockets and the
poison and this and that.
What about the gun?
Hey,
throw it in the candy drawer,
put it under your pillow.
Kid's never going to get there.
Yeah,
I mean,
there,
there's a lot of responsibility.
I don't mean to laugh,
but I mean I'm laughing at the
ridiculous of it and that,
and that is true and I think the vast
majority of gun owners are,
are um,
responsible.
You know,
it is another group that's painted with
the broad brush,
right?
That the few gun nuts,
crazy.
What the paint every NRA member as being
one of them.
And that isn't true.
You know,
like I said,
I know,
I know people love people who like guns
and they're not that.
But the people who are not that happy to
accept the fact that there is a
population that is that,
you know what I mean,
you,
you can't say that they don't exist
because they do exist.
So a big part of this,
I think like any other issue,
Joe,
we got to start telling each other the
truth.
You know what I mean?
About,
about these issues.
Like we,
everyone has their,
their side,
right,
or their tribe or their team and they
refuse to believe any truth,
you know,
any,
any negative truth about their team or
whatever.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like to say,
well,
like we were saying like gun owners.
Okay.
So there's responsible gun owners and
then there's a few gun blog and just use
the term gun nuts.
And the responsible gun owners have to
accept the fact that there was some gun
nuts,
right?
With the police.
The vast majority of police are good,
but the good police have to say,
yeah,
there are some bad cops too.
You know what I mean?
Like within any,
within it,
any tribe.
We're comics.
We know there are some bad comics.
I don't know if you know what Joe,
but I'm going to put it out there.
I heard of him,
but,
but until we,
until we do,
we can never
have a real discussion.
Right?
Because everybody just suddenly circles
the wagons around their hurt and like,
no,
not really.
No.
It's like,
no,
we're not saying all of you are bad,
but let's admit within your group there
is bad.
So we can work on that.
Yeah.
I've seen some tweets from some NRA
supporters the last day and a half that
are just fucking stunned me were just
shut the fuck up man.
Just really realize what the state of
all this is right now and shut the fuck
up.
And by the way,
there's a video that's going around that
somebody put up about me talking about
gun control is not a recent video.
I don't know when it's from,
but people are putting it up now about
me,
uh,
destroying the gun control argument.
Uh,
it's,
it would be very insensitive for me to
do that and to put that up right now.
And I didn't.
It had nothing to do with.
I don't know when it was,
I think it was from a year or so ago,
but,
but the idea that these people,
these NRA supporters would go and tweet
these pro gun messages and get crazy
with it now is exactly what you're
saying.
They're digging their heels in their
supporting their team.
Yeah.
And,
and as many people have been saying and,
and it is a sad truth.
Look,
if we didn't wake up after Sandy Hook
then you know,
if,
when 20,
was it 21 kids were shot.
Yeah.
That and people denied that it happened
to,
Oh that didn't even happen at all that,
you know what I mean?
People are calling this a false flag.
Right.
So,
so if that didn't wake us up,
yeah.
Then,
you know,
58 people at a music concert.
I hate to say it,
but it's like,
it's not going to wake us up.
You know,
I have,
I have a thing.
What Waking Sop mean?
You know,
I mean,
wake us up to the point of take some
action,
but what's the,
of President Alonza,
what would you do the,
the,
um,
well,
to start with,
we have to have the conversation.
We have to have the conversation about.
They're just,
like we just talked about.
There isn't a necessary.
It is necessary to change our gun laws
are gun laws are too lax.
That's the first thing.
Then what we need to do,
we need to come up with a system just
like we have with cars or anything else
dangerous where you,
you have to be trained to use it.
You have to register whatever it is with
the government and you have to have
liability insurance and that and that,
that information transfer is like the
big loophole is the gun shows,
right where you go to the gun show and
you could just sell a gun to another
person.
You can do that with all the case in a
lot of states that still the case.
You can do that with a car,
right?
I can sell you my car through Craig's
list,
but I'm still going to go put it in that
a liability thing.
Otherwise I'm liable for what you do
with the car.
Like I protect myself by reporting it
even though I sold it to you per party
to party.
Yeah.
So,
so yeah,
if I'm in charge,
we're gonna,
we're gonna add those things.
We're going to get.
We're going to get a handle on these
guns.
We're going to get start tracking how
many they are,
where they are,
we're going to collect them.
Um,
I think it was Australia and some other
places that had those things were looked
Australia.
If you own an illegal weapon,
like a fully automatic weapon or
whatever makes it illegal,
you can turn it in.
Maybe there's payment or maybe it's just
no questions asked,
just turn it in and we'll,
we'll destroy it.
Well,
what happened in Australia as they had a
mass shooting and then they put their
foot down and I said,
no,
Mark Australia just banned them
altogether.
Totally random.
You can still use a rifle to hunt.
But um,
the way we have this sort of fast and
loose,
there's very few countries in the world
that have this kind of fast and loose
gun policy.
I think.
Yeah,
we still have the wild west mentality.
Well,
freedom mentality,
which bill o'reilly did a fucking had a
post today where he's talking about that
this is the cost of freight.
The freedom.
Yeah.
Fucking crazy.
No,
it's not.
it's not the old dickhead.
And I'll give you an example,
Joe.
Like I grew up in New York City,
like guns had been illegal in New York
City for a long time.
Now there are guns in New York City,
but not as many as people think,
you know,
because what happens is when you make it
illegal,
then the average person,
they don't go out of their way to get a
gun.
Now I'm not,
I'm not going to have one.
Yeah,
a criminal is going to have guns.
Yes.
Criminals are always going to have guns.
But you know,
the thing about the good guy shooting
the bad guy,
it doesn't happen that often.
And my personal belief on this is
because in that moment it takes a lot to
shoot somebody.
It just happened the other day.
They just happened the other day saying
that doesn't happen.
There was an active shooter somewhere
that was taken out by a,
a good guy,
a gun on her.
It can happen.
You're right.
It doesn't happen everywhere all the
time.
But it can happen in a lot of people get
their guns stolen or taken away because
in that moment they can't use it.
Sure.
And the criminal,
he ain't got nothing to lose.
He's already a criminal.
You know what I mean?
It's also probably used to violence.
Yeah.
A lot of people are not used to
violence.
There's a lot of soft people out there
that they don't know what to do if the
shit hits the fan in any way,
shape or form,
they just don't know how to handle
pressure.
Yeah.
And,
and it's,
you know,
that happens in the neck.
So they buy a gun to protect themselves,
but they're in no way equipped to use
it.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of that.
They're hoping that they can use it or
to scare people off or something like
that,
but most likely,
yeah,
they're not going to be able to do it,
but you know,
then there's people that say,
well,
that's them.
I want the option because I will be able
to figure it out,
you know,
because I'm not a pussy or I'm not.
Then there's a legal way to get one
thing,
you know,
you do what it takes to and you register
it.
And again,
most gun owners that I know,
and I may be wrong because it's not like
I'm deep in the gun culture,
so I'm not speaking with that expertise.
I'm just talking about,
of the people I know who have guns,
who are into guns and shooting.
I only have one friend who's like,
doesn't want to register his guns or,
or anything like that.
Most of them I know they're fine with
their gun residue.
One
friend's argument,
uh,
I couldn't even tell you.
I honestly couldn't say I love him.
I love him when it comes to guns.
He's got a little,
he's got some of that paranoia.
He's got some of that,
the government government or no,
and then you know,
his thing with we were talking about,
and I know it's the wrong term,
but it's the common term assault
weapons,
assault type weapons.
Right?
And he said like,
yeah,
well what if there's a home invasion?
That's what they use.
And I was like,
ain't nobody invading your broke ass
home.
You ain't going to want to get your,
you know what I mean?
You got you.
Got You an average American with a two
bedroom in the suburbs.
Ain't nobody invading your shit.
You ain't got a safe.
If you were selling crack,
you might want to worry.
You might have some cash around the
house.
Even if you were a good marijuana
distributor,
there'd be a bunch of cash.
You're not allowed to put in the bank,
but you ain't nobody invading your
house.
Yeah.
Everybody wants to be John Wick.
Fucking take out a whole crew of people
breaking into your house flooded and
people over staircases.
John Wick's,
bad ass.
I love John.
I ain't got a lot of fun.
I love John Wayne my all time favorite.
Nobody's sitting around talking about
John Wick.
When you meet John Wick,
your shit is over.
That's Kiana reeves.
Best role.
Oh Man.
That's the matrix.
That scene when the.
When the gangster calls John Leguizamo
and it's like,
did you hit my son?
Yeah.
Why he stole John Wick's car and killed
his dog.
Thank you.
Yeah,
that's a great movie.
Both of them are great.
I enjoyed the second one too.
Silly.
Preposterous,
unrealistic but awesome.
Right?
I mean if you're,
if you like that sort of John Woo type
violence.
Yeah,
just off the charts.
Ridiculous gun violence.
But it's cartoonish and comic book.
Right.
It's not real.
And Kiano plays it,
you know,
he,
he's so good at it.
Like he plays it perfectly,
but just like,
just like any other movie,
the bad guys can't shoot.
Right.
So there's 25 guys shooting at him.
One of them might wing him when grades
his shoulder.
It was getting shot in the shoulder a
little bit.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know what the argument is for
not registering guns.
That makes sense because I mean unless
you just want a world where everybody
just pack and like there's like a few
states where you have a concealed and
open carry that you're just allowed to
allowed to have a gun on your hip and
just walk everywhere or they have the
test but it's like I'm like,
it used to be here with traffic school
where you just pay the guy and he gives
you the certificate that you went or
like they do these tests for carrying
concealed,
but it's like you can do it online,
you know it.
It's crazy.
So it's,
well you're getting dudes in Texas,
you can do your hunting safety
certificate online.
A couple of places
where you can get most places you have
to go and for $100 safety certificate
you have to sit down through a,
I think it's eight hours of class and go
through all this stuff.
Then you have to take a test and you
have to understand things.
Yep.
Does it transfer from one state to the
other leg?
In other words,
your,
your license to hunt and Texas.
That's good.
For some other states,
yeah,
if you have 100 safety certificate in
Texas,
it's.
It's good I think in almost every state,
but I mean that's.
That's a good thing.
It's a good thing to be,
to have to have some knowledge of what
safety and it's about.
It's called a hunter safety thing.
It's not even about knowing how to hunt.
It's just about knowing how to not get
shot or shoot yourself or shoot someone
else and how a gun works and how a all
various weapons.
Bows and arrows.
Crossbows and stuff work.
You don't have to do any of those.
Get a gun though.
I mean if you just had to go through an
eight hour course to get a gun,
how many less people would have guns?
She had a pass an eight hour course to
legally have a gun.
How many fewer people would have gotten?
It would probably be like 30 percent of
the people that have guns now.
Well mean also,
you know,
they're saying this is the wrong kind of
politicize it at which yeah,
it is.
It's time for a politician to stand up
to the NRA.
It's not politicized because every
politician is afraid to say we need to
register all the guns because the NRA is
going to attack,
you know,
they have their whole lobby machine,
but,
but it's going to take a politician who
has the balls to say,
Hey,
wait a minute,
I can get as many people following me,
like in other words,
challenge the NRA and get as many people
backing you as the NRA has the best way
to do it for these people to not say
shit.
When they don't say shit,
then they don't get the tax.
What I'm saying,
they're afraid.
They're afraid right now to politicians
who know better,
who absolutely know better,
who know that our current situation is
ridiculous and our system is broken in,
in the gun laws.
None of them will stand up and say,
yeah,
now except the ones that the NRA already
hates.
Right?
Bernie Sanders type of characters,
right?
Yeah.
There's again,
it's the team thing,
right?
Yeah.
You're supporting the left.
They're supporting the right.
Everybody meets in the middle and they
yell at each other.
Yeah,
and,
and this is a,
you know,
this is not a left,
right?
This is just a,
it's another one of those common sense
issues where we don't have common sense.
Like I,
I joke sometimes on state,
like I'm going to Canada next week I'm
doing a tour and I had had this joke
like,
can you explain it to a Canadian like
that should be to test for what sane can
you explain it to a Canadian?
I was doing it regarding healthcare,
like try to explain to a Canadian why
we've demonized healthcare,
why we want to shut that out.
And you do,
you can't even make meaning that
they're,
they're anti obamacare.
So rather than look for a compromise or
fix the system,
just shut it down because it's called
Obamacare,
right?
Like the,
just the anger at the name.
You lie like that famous night that
Kimmel did where it was like,
are you against obamacare?
I hate obamacare.
What about the affordable care act?
Oh,
I like that.
It's the same thing.
Yeah,
exactly.
And he did a man on the street and
that's what,
you know so many people were.
And that's what I mean by demonize,
you attached this name to it.
So people just are anti just based on
that without looking at any rather than
saying,
okay,
like maybe this part like to no
preexisting is part of the healthcare
plan.
That's a good idea.
So we're going to keep that.
But maybe the cost of this is a bad
idea.
So we're gonna change that,
you know what I mean?
And working to fix it.
The gun issue is the same way.
There's certain freedoms that I
understand and you,
you know,
the right to bear arms and so on.
And again it was written in a completely
different time,
you know,
so we need to update that,
right?
Taking into account everything that we
deal with today.
Well one step at a time.
If you're going to talk about the
affordable care act,
if you get to talk about healthcare at
all,
you're gonna have to talk about what are
the real issues,
like what,
what are the root causes of diseases,
you know,
and a big part of the root causes
diseases or how people eat and.
Oh yeah,
I mean if people eat poorly and they
consume a lot of refined carbohydrates
and a lot of processed sugars and they
know their diet is filled with bullshit
and they're drinking every day and
they're smoking cigarettes.
Like,
man,
if you want to make those choices with
your life,
you are going to get diseases.
There's just,
it's almost an extra right.
And you.
And then you start battling the
corporations and you know,
big food and stuff like that because you
know,
why it's so much cheaper to poorly,
but just think,
well that's because it's cheaper to
produce.
But we think about the,
uh,
the,
the actual physical numbers of people
that die every year from heart disease.
Oh absolutely.
It's fun
because,
you know,
look at the amount of,
of,
of fast food we consume.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's like fast food is an evil.
There's times when you know you're on
the run and you want to grab a burger,
you want to grab for it.
Good.
You're a whole dot okay.
But.
Right.
But it can't be the only thing you eat
all the time.
You saw supersize me,
right?
Yeah.
I mean it ain't good.
No,
it's not good to know.
Just constant bullshit.
Right?
Well you can't eat that much salt and
grease all the time and not have
anything you do.
There's a penalty.
No Salsa but nxs.
Yeah,
it's all bullshit.
That's that whole thing about salt being
bad for you in salt,
raising high blood pressure and all that
stuff that was kind of concocted by one
doctor and ran with is really very
little evidence about that.
I don't know.
I'm black.
God told us not to eat,
so they tell you not to eat fatty foods
either.
But meanwhile it's refined carbohydrates
that are.
The real issue is sugar and everything
is in sugar and we are addicted.
We are shooting addicts,
sugar,
corn syrup.
I mean.
And then there's also all these studies
that talked to you about red meat,
but when you look at the studies about
red meat and you look at the criticisms
of studies,
like people that eat red meat get more
cancer will.
The real criticism of those studies is
what are you eating with the red meat?
Because are you eating like lean
like grass fed bison with like asparagus
and Broccoli?
I bet you're pretty fucking healthy if
you're doing that.
The real issues are you eating burgers?
They don't differentiate between the
two.
When you talk about people that eat red
meat five times a week and the
correlation between cancer,
they're literally not even taking into
consideration what they eat.
What that red meat are they eating white
bread or the eating sugary soda?
This again Joe,
this is what we're talking about the
same thing because it's like the common
sense argument is eliminated because of
common sense arguments.
Quiet.
So you have the loud yelling or if
course of of you know the meat lobby
versus whoever,
whoever's the anti meet people.
And so you know what I mean?
And the common sense is in between,
like you said,
there's healthy ways to eat meat or
maybe you don't need it every with every
meal or not every day you mix it up or
stuff like that.
It's not meat,
but,
but needed something that human beings
at eating forever.
But ways to eat carbohydrates,
sugars,
say healthy ways to eat meat.
I mean,
what you're saying,
what you eat around it,
how is it prepared?
Right.
And so on that,
that can make it,
that can be the difference between
healthy and unhealthy.
You know,
chicken,
you know,
is,
is supposed to be good for it.
But,
but,
you know,
fried chicken deep fried chicken has
been sitting in the grease for x number
of hours waiting for you to kind of pick
it up.
Flower,
right?
Exactly.
It's not,
you know,
that is not a healthy way to eat
chicken.
Delicious.
Resize me to.
You'll never look at chicken the same
way he's doing this.
Take that down.
Don't ruin chicken for me.
I have
an issue with him though.
He did a show where he was,
um,
he did like 30 days.
Is that,
was that the name of his show and one of
the things he did was on hormone
replacement surgery or hormone
replacement,
like testosterone replacement and things
along those lines,
but I know for a fact that the producer
has tried to go to legitimate doctors
and the doctors turned them down because
they said,
this is not how you do it.
You don't do anything like that over 30
days.
Hold on a second.
So when he did for that show,
because he went to a quack,
quack,
shot him up a testosterone,
not him.
The guy on the show that he uses a study
case and they shot this guy up with
testosterone.
When the guy started getting aggressive
and yelling at his kids and his wife was
like,
I like you Chubby,
Chubby,
Chubby family.
I'm like,
this is the dumbest fucking example of
the science behind manipulating your
hormones,
like the way you're supposed to do at
his first address,
your diet.
Number one,
you take your diet into consideration
like,
what are you eating?
Are you getting these gigantic insulin
spikes all day?
Like your hormone levels are completely
dependent upon what kind of food you
consume,
so what they would do in a,
in a healthy doctor,
the doctor that I was using this don't
say his name,
but he was.
What he would do is for like the first
couple months,
the first thing you would do is change
your diet.
The first thing you would do is don't
eat late at night.
The first thing you would do eat healthy
food
and they would literally check your,
your blood nutrition levels and say,
well,
you are.
You're low on Niacin.
You're low on vitamin D,
you're low in vitamin B.
You got to add these to your diet.
Let's see what your hormone levels are
like.
Then,
oh look,
we have this big spike now we have a
healthy baseline.
Now we've done this for four or five
months.
Now we know where you're at and what you
need in this.
They didn't do that.
They just shot him up with some shit.
So that guy in his show,
I,
I had problems with them ever since and
I'm like,
why would you like that sensationalism?
That's bullshit.
Like what you've done is you put
together a show where you've had a
terrible representation of something
that uh,
millions of people engage in hormone
replacement.
Well,
even in supersize me,
even if you ate at Mcdonald's,
you wouldn't eat as much as he did.
Right?
You wouldn't supersize every meal.
And that was the deal though.
He said if they offered him supersize he
was going to say they always do.
They always offered up upsides.
You.
Yeah.
But then I've heard people also say
they've done the same thing they've done
that supersize me diet and try it for 30
days and they didn't have nearly the
negative responses and they thought that
that they might've sensationalize that
as well.
They probably did.
I mean it's TV.
Right?
But in that case,
and yeah,
and it's also,
you know,
you talk about hormones and things like
that,
different people react to things
different ways.
Sure.
You know,
their,
their bodies,
some people's.
But,
and,
and you know,
it drives you crazy,
right?
That person,
you know,
that each junk food all the time,
but it has this crazy metabolism and
they never gained weight.
Twinkie Diet helps nutrition professor
lose 27 pounds.
Then.
There you go.
Yeah,
let's pull.
Pull this up here just to prove the
calories in,
calories out thing.
But there's a caveat in this to this.
It doesn't have any,
uh,
hold on hormone stuff.
Go down.
Let me see it from the top.
Uh,
for 10 weeks,
mark,
how professor of nutrition at Kansas
State University ate one of these sugary
cake,
gets every three hours instead of meals
to add variety to his steady stream of
hostess and Little Debbie snacks.
How munched on Doritos chips,
sugary cereal and Oreos,
Oreos to his premise that in weight
loss,
pure calorie counting is what matters
most,
not the nutritional value of the food.
Uh,
the premise held up a on this
convenience store die.
He shed 27 pounds in two months.
But here's the thing,
what does his body fat like?
What's his body composition?
Stop,
go back.
See,
like he's shed 27 pounds in two months.
That doesn't mean anything.
Like if you lost all of your muscle and
gain fat and you lost,
I mean,
you got to understand like if you're not
taking in any protein,
your body's not gonna.
Be able to maintain muscle mass.
Now,
if your body's not going to maintain
muscle mass,
you're going to have less.
See,
see his body fat mass index went from 28
point eight,
considered overweight to 24 point nine,
which is normally not always 174 pounds.
Hmm?
His bad cholesterol.
Ldl drop 20 percent and is good.
Cholesterol.
Hdl increased by 20 percent.
He reduced the level of triglycerides,
which are a form of fat by 39 percent.
That's where the head scratching comes
from.
Hub says,
uh,
what does that mean?
Does it mean I'm healthier?
Does it mean how we define health from a
biological standpoint that we're missing
something?
Just temporary success.
He does not remember.
Look,
take rebellion.
Yeah.
He also,
oh,
wait a minute.
He also took a multivitamin pill and
drink a protein shake daily and the ate
vegetables typically a can of can of
green beans or three or four celery
stalks.
All right,
well that's,
that's a stupid study.
He's replacing something.
Nutrients,
vitamins.
Yeah.
So he's not living on twinkies and yeah,
that's bullshit.
And uh,
the retos yeah,
if you just did that without the,
without the protein and what the vine,
it would've been a different result.
But people love.
I mean,
that's why we're reading it.
We're reading it because he got a
sensational results.
And,
and the way it was written,
this sensational part.
What's the first part of the article?
Of course.
And you had to go way down before you
got to the part about eating vegetables
and drinking a protein shake.
Yeah.
Don't eat little debbie cakes all day.
Folks.
Don't do that.
You'll get fucked up if you've learned
anything today.
You cannot live on twinkies,
but every now and then have a fucking
twinkie.
You know,
I believe everything in moderation,
including moderation.
That's what I believe.
I think that's an Oscar wilde quote.
I think it's a great quote because I
think that's good.
I mean even just have some bullshit
every now and then have a big Mac,
you know that people have the cheat day
or whatever.
And yeah,
and you gotta it's because you're human,
you're human and you're going to have it
and some of it's delicious.
It's fun.
It's fun to eat a waffle smothered in
maple syrup.
It's fun.
Every now and then to go to fucking
waffle house.
You go to waffle house on the road.
Of course I've worked with south your
waffle house.
We have the ability to waffle house when
they were on both sides of the freeway.
So no matter which ramp you come off,
you don't have to turn.
The South has waffle houses.
It's like the West has in and out.
The South has waffle house,
you know,
they,
they put it in and out in Dallas and he
had lines around the block days for
days.
People like people had never seen a
fucking cheeseburger before.
And you know,
who was mad?
Who Water Burger.
Oh yeah.
Texas is Texas Burger chain out and step
your fucking in and out came in and they
were like,
wait a minute,
everyone's lining up for that California
Liberal Burger.
Yeah.
Well,
if you're the unknown comic and you're
playing at a club and Chris rock is at
the fucking arena next door,
you can't get pissed off.
Someone's got a better product than you.
Let me,
let me speak from experience to that.
Joe,
let me speak from experience.
I was booked at,
what's it called?
The club 29 or whatever.
That casino.
Just past palm springs.
I don't know if you grew up.
Worked out there,
but anyway,
one of those big Indian casinos and and
I had never worked this place before,
so I'm booked to work the comedy club
inside.
Guess who's working the arena behind the
Kotel.
Have Kevin Hart,
Chris Rock,
Chris Rock.
And I was like,
even I want to go to the Chris rock
show.
Know what I mean?
Like really your ideas to put me in
Chris on at the same week.
You couldn't think of some other comic.
When was this was?
It was about four years ago,
but it was just one of those things,
you know,
his picture's on,
on the tables and everything.
And I was like,
I want to go to the Chris rock show
though.
People at my show.
I'm like,
why are you here?
Why don't we all just go out and watch
Chris Water Burger step your game up
there or burgers are okay.
Water burgers.
Okay.
In and out.
Better in and out is way better.
I'll tell you what,
those five guys fucks within and out.
Five guys got game.
You got five guys.
Five guys has fucking Jalapenos and put
Jalapenos on those burgers.
Fries.
You got five guys.
You got five guys next to in and out
across the street from what?
A Burger.
You Got America dammit.
Yeah.
You got five guys.
Fucks up.
They fuck up or they don't have shakes.
They don't go with checks.
Then I'm shaking,
but their burgers are God damn good
burgers.
Good fries are good.
Fries.
Potatoes.
He had.
The potatoes are better.
Yeah.
It seemed to have a better idea of what?
A fries.
And then they have Cajun fries.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
I'm dumb.
But I guess.
Well that's why they're in the game.
What about a steak and shake?
What do you think of that can suck my
dick.
I said it right here.
Peanuts,
peanuts,
baphy that hungry.
Hungry.
It's nothing wrong with peanuts unless
you've got a peanut allergy,
of course.
Which is another thing we're talking
about how different people react to
different things.
The peanut allergy is always like the
best argument.
This is the new thing,
and I've only heard this recently,
actually this year is the first time I
heard it where they're like,
you can't have anything peanut related
on an airplane because a passenger has a
severe peanut allergy.
Yeah.
Well something.
I hadn't heard that until this year.
I've heard it.
When you crack open a peanut,
you know that dust to kind of goes in
the air.
That shit kills people.
Wow.
Which is nuts.
Yeah.
Imagine if you didn't,
you didn't like somebody you got right
up to him and just see a shit cracking
in their face.
That would be some CSI shit.
Like they'd have to figure out how you
killed him.
Who opened the peanut?
Yeah.
You know,
I was thinking this is a terrible
thought,
but I was thinking this about Tom Petty.
I was like a wonder if Tom Petty,
you heard the news about Vegas and had a
fucking heart attack.
Can you imagine if that got killed?
Tom Petty from a distance could happen.
Is that.
How did Tom Petty had a heart attack?
Did he know about what time was his
heart attack?
Was it Sunday night or was it Sunday Day
then?
How old was he?
Sixty six,
man.
That ain't real.
Yeah,
66.
The loans still fucking kicking ass and
action movies still is.
I think Liam.
Liam Neeson was taken the second time.
I'm just thinking if I'm a thug,
I can't let a 70 year old whip my ass.
You know what I'm saying?
There's a certain age where it's like,
no man,
you.
I don't care how long you been fighting.
What training you had listened old man.
I'm in my thug prime,
who's like the oldest guy who
legitimately make sense as like a stone
cold killer and a movie was at Bronson,
but Charles Bronson deathwish,
he was already here.
We're already like fat Charles Bronson.
He got like the Chubby face and you
couldn't take his suit off.
Whereas like he go back to like the hard
times Bronson,
he was 50,
he was going to shred,
shredded.
I'm just,
I'm trying to think as anyone in their
sixties legitimate to whip your ass.
Like physically not,
not shoot you,
but George Foreman.
Fuck you up.
Yeah.
Well he's,
he's a puncher.
Yeah.
George Foreman's probably 60 years old
that he'll fight Stevens.
What did he call it?
Steven Seagal.
Oh,
George Foreman.
What?
Get the fuck Outta here.
Oh,
after craziness.
What is,
what was the golf talking crazy.
You can do anything you want 10 rounds,
something like that.
That is so ridiculously stupid if Steven
Seagal,
because all you'd have to do is pour
water on his head and that black shit
would just run down into his eyes and
wouldn't be able to say what does it
say?
George Foreman just challenged Steven
Seagal to a no holds barred fight.
Boy,
that would be a God damn disaster.
Sixty eight year old boxing legend.
Use twitter to challenge 65 year old
action movies,
but I've got a $68.
I bet every
fucking eight year old former in versus
65 year olds to go
of challenge you one on one.
I use boxing.
You can use whatever,
10 rounds in Vegas.
No weapons hand to handling.
That will be a fucking disaster.
First of all,
George Foreman is so big that he had
this shall defense that he adopted later
in his career where he would curl up.
Right,
and he was so big.
There was so much arm there.
You couldn't hit anything.
You hit his stomach.
Could luck with all that.
You're not going to hurt them to the
body.
And then he's got these hands that are
literally like canned hams and he just.
He would just jab people into a coma.
Should a guy,
I think he's playing for the Milwaukee
Bucks.
His hands around the basketball.
Could you see that?
He literally his.
It's like a soft ball in his hands.
The people that are getting bigger and
bigger and bigger and bigger.
I mean go back to like Jack Johnson who
was a giant when he won the heavyweight
championship.
It's only sex too.
It was not wanting to go to a big guy,
you know,
my,
a big hand moment earlier this year.
I did a show and Oh,
look at that guy's hands that show.
Show them around the basketball.
If you have that picture that looks
cartoonish,
that doesn't even look real good that
that guy must have a dick.
Like a palm tree.
Jesus Christ.
Holy Shit.
It's two feet from his middle finger to
the base of his hand.
That's insane.
Is that?
Yes.
Centimeters.
Centimeters in my.
Less with the centimeters.
Communist.
Same size as Jerry Rice's.
So yeah,
that makes sense.
So I got back.
There it is.
Look at that.
Well,
how old was he then in high school then
it looks like Jesus Christ.
Wow.
They call them the Greek freak.
Yeah,
the Greek freak.
He's amazing because he Greek.
I can't relate to the coop.
Whoa,
whoa.
What's the name?
Oh,
it needs a hell of a ball player.
Tick.
How do you say that?
Onto Kupo.
Onto tongue tip.
Toe to toe.
Cone onto.
To come.
So he's from Greece.
Yeah.
Interesting.
I mean like what if that guy gets a hold
of like a Gabrielle Reece,
she's already married,
but you know,
something along those lines.
A large woman like the woman from game
of thrones,
but that picture a hold of her,
shoot some super sperm in there,
make some giant data.
Next generation's going to be a hell of
a lot with animals for sport.
What sport would that kid go into?
Any party wants fucking sporty once
everybody get out of the way.
What about Aaron?
Judge six,
seven to 80 playing baseball.
You see how that looks in his hand?
The Bat looks like a little twig,
like he's swinging a kid's back.
What are you seeing that though?
That's one thing that's interesting.
Like that guy in the past might've gone
into football,
but now guys we're looking at football.
I'm like,
fuck that.
I don't blame them.
I don't blame.
There's guys that are retiring at 24,
25 years old.
Why am I going to have a three year
career with possible concussion damage
and everything is possible when I could
play baseball or basketball for 10 years
and and leave with $100,
million dollars and just fuck everything
that moves.
Yeah.
They did a study on former basketball
players or former football players were
either in a hundred 11 players.
One hundred and 10 of them had cte
cheese.
Hundred and 10 out of 111.
Yeah.
There's the guy who was the doctor
behind that movie concussion.
He was recently talking about Oj Simpson
because Oj Simpson was released and he's
like,
there's 100 percent chance that guy has
cte and they've even said that Oj,
if the trial was today,
his doctor said that he would introduce
cte as a defense offense,
which is crazy because then you have to
say he's guilty because the defect is
always.
I didn't do it,
you know,
until he wrote a book how I did it.
Yeah.
If I did it,
that was the book.
I know,
but if it's in tiny little red one and I
did it.
I watched the Cuba gooding show last
night to fx show.
I'd never seen.
You'd never seen people versus Oj
Simpson.
Great.
It was a great record.
You great show.
You know.
It's weird to watch man to,
to revisit everything.
Cool.
The night when the Oj got out,
it's like,
just go away.
Yeah,
just go quiet.
Don't say anything.
Play Golf and keep your mouth shut.
He doesn't do this.
He's not going to.
And he can't.
He's a.
he's addicted to love.
He's addicted to people liking them and
there's going to always,
if he goes to Florida,
there's plenty of fucking stupid people
in.
It's going to take them right there.
Easy.
Or He's going back to jail.
He's gonna.
Do something stupid and violate his
parole.
Do you think you'll do that though at
seven years old or whatever he is?
Well,
if he does anything other than shut up,
he's either going to die or go back to
jail.
You know what I mean?
Like there's no,
there's no positive that's going to come
out of him making public appearances.
You know,
writing a book,
going on the talk show circuit,
like no,
like you're 70 years old,
live out the last 10,
15,
20 years,
whatever you got just lifted.
There's.
And there's money somewhere,
right?
Because Florida,
they couldn't take his money,
like moved there.
So he's gotten money somewhere.
Just just quietly fade away.
You know,
like people,
people might recognize you when you go
down to play Bingo at the home.
Just wave bank some oprah in the,
you know.
But,
but yeah,
there's no,
I don't think there's any way.
There's no positive public appearance.
No.
That Oj could make.
The attorney general,
I think it was Florida was saying that
she didn't want him hopping around her
state playing,
you know,
playing golf,
which is,
by the way
state honey,
just let you know,
you know,
it's fucking in the sense that she's the
top cop and she can prosecute him for
any made up shit she wants
do that.
That's not America.
See when someone gets a fucking release,
right,
you're released,
you're on parole,
you're released from prison.
You can't just target someone because
they're famous and they had been
released through you.
You're dealing with a million fucking
murderers are getting out every day.
You're dealing with.
I'm not a million obviously,
but you're dealing with a shit ton of
people that were armed robbers and have
committed assault and rape.
They're getting out.
Huh?
But again,
Joe,
you're talking about,
and we were talking about this earlier,
theoretical versus reality in theory,
this is the United States of America and
you have freedoms and they can't do that
to you in reality.
Hell yeah.
They can do it because it's like if they
follow you around,
right?
If a cop followed you all day every day,
you would break the law,
do you think so you.
Yeah.
You don't know how.
You know it might be Jaywalking,
it might be speeding,
it might be whatever.
You know what I mean?
But you would do something that would
violate some statute that you didn't
know about you.
What you might be.
Well maybe you,
you know,
I got that whole driving while black
thing going for me when y'all saw crazy
motorcycle rider.
That's true.
I got that.
I need to ask you,
as we brought this up the last time,
who was it on the podcast?
We were talking about a bike that you
had.
It was with Burton.
Remember the bike that you have,
but you had some crazy giant wide
Japanese super bike or a cruiser?
It's trial.
It's called the triumph rocket three.
Is that a trial?
That's what I'm talking about.
It's a two point three liter motorcycle,
but it's.
It's the engine is,
is bigger than a lot of car engines and
the bike itself,
the bike is the bike itself,
but this isn't talking about.
No,
no,
no.
It was from a long time ago,
man.
It's from like 10 years ago.
You had,
you had this crazy wide bike that was a
Japanese bike.
Maybe it was a Suzuki Hio Bussa.
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't one of those like rice rocket
bikes wasn't my Ducati I had accustomed
to.
No,
it was a Japanese Japanese,
but it was a big ass cruiser.
It was one of those.
Oh,
I know what you're talking about.
You're talking about.
It's called the valkyrie ruined run.
Oh yeah.
I remember that.
Yeah.
Had that.
As a matter of fact,
that's what I had before the trial.
Right.
I couldn't remember the name of that
damn good recall Joe.
Yeah.
That bike was.
That bike was one of a kind that looked
like a spaceship.
Like you were in that tron movie,
you know.
There it is.
That's it.
No,
that's not it.
no.
That's the Valkyrie.
But look up argue and he ruined.
Yeah.
So there's a different valcon we ruined
with a custom version.
They said.
Yeah,
it was a Honda.
I think that was it.
Yeah.
You had,
you had that,
had that,
that bike was bad.
Know.
Bring it to the factors.
Yeah.
I saw that thing and I was like,
what the fuck is part of why I got rid
of that bike,
Joe?
I'll be honest.
Polishing that thing.
That thing had more chrome in more
places.
I'm telling you,
look at everything on that bike was
chromed engine,
the entire front end and I was like,
man,
I can't spend all day cleaning.
It was a great bike though.
It seems like a bike where if you
accidentally laid it down,
it would take forever to get that thing
back up to 800 pounds,
100 pounds for a beautiful,
you know,
you know who bought a a group of those
who,
Clooney,
George Clooney,
clooney,
but six of them.
Why?
For him and his buddies for him and his
buddies to variety bucks.
$6.
Damn is this,
you know,
I'm just like,
you don't have fat ass like that.
Look how cool that paint job is on that
thing.
He did that.
That's custom paint that now do they
still make that thing?
No,
they only made it for a.
They made it for one year.
It was like a limited.
Yeah,
like a limited release.
They did it for one year.
He must have been stupid fast.
It was pretty fast.
It was,
yeah.
It was pretty fast for Cruz who's very
fast now.
Those comfortable to ride.
It's not like the idea behind them.
It's comfortable because somebody
pushing you.
Right now I have an Indian chieftain.
Right.
And this was my first,
like American v twin kind of cruiser and
I've never been that guy.
Like,
you know,
I've never had a harley or anything,
but I saw this bike,
the dealer and it was just absolutely
beautiful.
And I wrote it and,
and I guess I'm getting older.
There was some about leaning back with
my feet forward and the stereo playing
and I was like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
I like this shit.
Like I,
I remember leaning forward like being a
jockey and going fast and now I'm like,
Nah,
this is me.
You like cruising now?
I like cruising.
I like touring.
I like going on trips.
Traveling right there.
Yeah,
the red one up in the top,
middle.
That's,
that's it.
Yeah.
I said,
man,
look at that thing.
Yeah,
I got it outside when we're done I'll
show it to you.
But those batches,
we keep stuff in those things.
What do you keep?
Yeah,
you can carry and keeping their high
keep.
That's why I use for whatever.
You know,
what you keep in there,
her purse.
Oh that's right.
Because this guy told me that,
uh,
they call those baggers that started a
bike and he said,
man,
chicks love baggers and he ain't kid and
stuff and they love it.
They love it.
But now that's a big cruiser,
right?
It's all loud bike.
No,
no,
it's not loud.
It,
it.
It'll be a little louder next year I'm
going to put pipes on it this winter and
Morocco,
but I'm not going.
I'm not going crazy.
Like straight pipes that,
you know,
set off car alarms and.
No,
I just a little,
little bit louder now when you have a
bike like that,
like the ideas that they're slower.
Right?
But they're more comfortable then you
know what that bike,
that bike is.
Sunset Strip and pch.
Ah,
just cruising.
You know that.
That's what that.
Yeah.
That's what that is.
Comfortable.
You look good.
You got a stereo and you just chilling.
Now when you say our stereo,
like you can hear it.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So you're blasting.
It's everybody here.
So yeah,
it's a little weird.
Like I don't like being that guy,
one of them at a light,
you know what I mean?
But,
but when you're riding along,
nobody's really hearing it that much,
you know,
you're passing people.
But yeah,
when you're sitting at a light.
So,
and I know guys who go with,
you know,
a thousand watts and they,
their bags,
their saddleback is a speaker.
Like they're,
they're broadcasting,
you know,
I don't want to be that guy,
but it is kind of Nice.
Again,
this is stuff that I hadn't done until I
got to spike.
Right?
But now I'm realizing I'm like,
this shit ain't bad if I'm cruising
down,
you know,
Holland or pch or something like that.
And I'm listening to music.
I'm like,
yeah,
I can hear the music over the sound of
the engine and the,
the,
uh,
the speakers are loud enough systems,
loud music blaring.
Mostly Jazz.
I'm chilling.
I'm a jazz jazz,
jazz and hip hop.
Those are my two.
You really do like jazz,
you one of those people I legitimately
love Jasmine on the jazz is one of those
things that like weird dudes put on to
pretend the girls that they're
sophisticated,
he likes,
there's some jazz that is like that and
I'll admit I had to like learn that
level of jazz.
Like there's a level of jazz that's
like,
I'm like,
this girl I dated,
she would be like,
are you listening to that sketchy jazz
shit?
That's the shit you have to listen to,
to learn.
Because in the beginning only meet other
musicians understand it.
Right.
And I know some jazz musicians and they
were breaking it down,
but there's a lot of jazz.
It's just,
I don't know.
I don't know how to explain it to music.
Played by master musicians and that's
what,
that's why it's good because when you
listen to a guy like Robert Glasper
who's really hot now or Herbie Hancock,
like when you listen to Herbie Hancock,
play a piano,
you're like,
oh,
that's how it's supposed to sound.
You know what I mean?
Because he's just.
He just has mastered that instrument.
You know,
so,
so yeah,
I listened to some of that and it and it
can be,
there's times when it's out there and
it's meditative and shit like that,
but don't get me wrong.
You might,
you know,
you might pass by.
I might be cranking Jay z,
you know,
I love hip hop,
love old school hip hop.
That shit.
I grew up with the old eighties.
Now you play music at all?
No.
So a lot of people that learned to jazz
actually played music.
Yeah,
a lot of them are.
I think I appreciate it because I have
no musical talent.
So the masters of it fascinate me and in
the last 10 years I've been doing like
these jazz cruises,
hosting jazz festivals and this and
that,
and I found it's really true.
Well you know this because you know,
musicians to that thing about every
musician wants to be a comic and every
comic wants to be a musician.
I definitely have this mutual admiration
thing with,
with jazz artists,
like,
man,
I wish I could play that.
And they're like,
man,
I wish I was funny.
Yeah.
Well there's,
there's something about.
They can,
not jazz necessarily,
but people in bands,
they can play the same shit forever.
One thing I can't do,
I get on jazz artists about that old
time.
Like they'll play like there's a track
called so what?
By Miles Davis,
right?
Classic.
Jazzy.
Like miles wrote this in 1959 and you
can play it and your considered
brilliant.
Hm.
How does that shit work?
How does that work?
At no point can I do Eddie Murphy's,
gunny boohoo and suddenly be that Alonza
was a brilliant comment.
You hear that goody Google maps for 59.
Fifty nine.
Yeah.
Fifty nine comedy.
Get fucking rockstar.
Not Weird.
Like comedy from 59.
It's terrible.
Yeah.
Try listening to some old Lenny Bruce,
so I'm a huge Lenny Bruce Fan.
I've framed Lenny Bruce posters in my
home,
but if you tried to listen to it today,
it's the culture has bypass these ideas.
Yeah,
it was revolutionary in groundbreaking
at the time because the culture was so
childish and infant tile and it's its
ideas and understanding of like weird
concepts are abstract concepts or things
like a censorship or or racism or any of
the things that when Bruce Cover.
Then when he was covering them back then
they were groundbreaking,
but now like a lot of the stuff he's
saying is just done.
But I think I think a lot of those
comics because years ago we were having
this debate.
This is before rape.
Okay.
We were having this debate about cosby.
You got to put that qualifier in
Brooklyn.
Yeah.
You always have to end.
It was.
If he started today,
would he make it?
And I argued yes because his comedy
would have been different.
Like he still,
you know what I mean,
like,
like Lenny Bruce,
he wouldn't have been talking about the
things he was talking about and 59 or
60,
he'd be talking about the same shit that
we talk about today,
but he still would have had that
brilliant comic mind and he still would
have been.
Who knows what he had been talking about
because he'd have been kicking down
doors today.
Sure.
So he would've been just at some,
you know,
different.
But I think those comics,
most of them,
that's the brilliant.
Definitely the brilliant ones.
The top ones would be funny today.
They just talk about the topics.
We talk about
100 percent.
Yeah,
I think so too.
I think it's just a matter of the time
and the error that they existed in and.
But conversely,
if you took someone from today,
like if you took dave chappelle and yet
dave chappelle doing standup at 1960,
they'd probably be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Yeah.
What are you doing?
You're talking about a baby selling
crap.
Kids didn't seem chappelle in 1959.
Never would have never.
Well just.
Well,
it's just,
it's not relevant,
right?
It has to be relevant to the time,
you know,
a brilliant comedian of today trying to
talk about the same subjects we talk
about today.
It's just you.
You know what I mean?
That's the weird thing about comedy
really does reflect the era in which
performed.
It's absolutely,
it's the culture that we're in.
I mean it was,
you know,
it was Vaudeville right when,
when all you had to do with juggle and
hit a guy
would hammer.
That was all,
you got that old hammer bit when they
were here would do like a Japanese
impression and put like a cigar in his
mouth,
you know,
like the buck to haul.
Why?
Why that?
I never understood that.
Like how does that represent Japanese
people?
The buck tooth thing.
Who was it to the debt?
There was a guy who did that.
I can't remember,
but I know you're talking about them.
Picture in it.
Yeah.
It definitely,
definitely what we do as well,
just in the time I'd say even in the
time we've been doing it.
I mean I started in [inaudible] 93 and
it's definitely different now than you
know,
than it was then.
That was def jam right when I was.
Excuse me,
when I started out def jam was it?
And,
and I caught a lot of hell being a black
comic who wasn't a def jam type out
comments.
It was like,
what the hell you talking about?
Right.
And it was like,
I'm on,
I'm on NPR,
you know,
which now is cool,
but in [inaudible] 94 probably wouldn't
have been the coolest,
coolest thing.
Oh
yeah.
Isn't that interesting?
Like uh,
you,
you get expected to fit into a certain
genre,
right?
Yeah.
And then there's like there's markets
for that genre.
Yeah.
Like when def jam
was big,
like there's a market for that kind of
comedy and a lot of you saw a lot of
comedians like mold themselves into that
market.
Yeah.
And I always thought,
and I was lucky in that a few of the
pros I'm like,
I remember like cedric the entertainer
was one and Tommy Davidson was another
and George Wallace was another who told
me like,
just do like,
do you like you cannot,
like don't worry about that shit because
the only thing worse than being a deaf
guy would not,
would be a fake def jam comic.
That was the only thing worse than not
fitting in would be a fake def jam.
Like for me to suddenly pretend like I
grew up in Queens.
I grew up in St Albans,
Queens,
working class,
black neighborhood.
My parents both had jobs,
but we had a house with a yard and the
two car garage and the whole bit.
Right.
Not Rich,
not poor,
just working class.
If I tried to come at you like I grew up
in the south bronx and I have friends
from the South Bronx,
you know,
I have friends from Bedstuy,
but it would have been fake and you'd
have seen right through it.
If you were from bed Stuy,
you'd have seen through my ass in a
minute.
You know,
I might have fooled you if you were
from,
you know,
I don't know,
Colorado or some shit for me.
Davidson,
Tommy Davidson.
Where's he at?
Tommy still out there.
Tommy still,
uh,
clubs and doing this thing on rare
occasions.
Once in a while,
but I'll always have love for Tommy.
Tommy helped me when I was new.
Tommy took me on the road with him for a
summer and I learned a lot and he
introduced me to clubs that I got into.
You know,
Tommy was.
Tommy was a brilliant talent.
Um,
the drug thing really hurt Tommy,
he went through that phase and I think
what hurt him with that was that he
developed a reputation for unreliability
where he,
you know,
people like is he going to show up?
And it was the worst thing to hear,
but talent wise,
he was just amazing.
Like I would watch Tommy worked some
nights when Tommy did a story and I
don't know how much you've ever seen him
on stage and with a bunch of the store
when he starts becoming each different
character in the story with his voices
and singing and shit.
Brilliant.
Yeah.
Really.
I used to watch that and just be blown
away that he had that kind of talent.
The fucking drug thing,
man,
that's the drug to that cocaine drug.
You know,
when you talk about the drug thing,
it's very rarely the pot.
That's always the drug thing.
It's like,
oh,
what's he doing?
You know,
math,
coke,
speed ones,
right.
Do people or the booze,
booze do people into.
Well,
the thing,
and you know,
we talked about on the last podcast,
I went through the coke and the crack
thing and what happens when you get
addicted to drugs like that,
they just dominate your life.
So you can't,
you can't do anything else because the
drug domination,
now it's heroin right now.
You've got people on oxy and heroin and,
and you know,
you literally see them in a nod.
I was in Cleveland
um,
early this past summer,
downtown Cleveland,
Ohio.
It's got this like one of the bad opioid
things and you would just literally see
people on the bench just nodding,
like going into it.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is,
you know,
this.
I mean it's been there but.
But when people are sitting out on a
park bench,
just going into a nod,
we got a problem.
Well,
the problem in Massachusetts to Rizza
Anthony Bourdain show he was doing about
it recently where the problem in
Massachusetts was that they were giving
out pain pills to people so easily.
Yeah.
And people got hooked and then when they
try to get off the pain pills,
because they were tightened down,
the read the regulations on them,
then people started turning to heroin.
Right.
And that was a thing in the nineties
with the opioids when,
when they came out with Oxycontin and
all those related drugs,
they told the doctor it's not,
it's not addicting.
Go ahead and write the prescription.
And now some of those pharmaceutical
companies are paying like big lawsuits
because they knew back then that it was
addicting.
Yeah.
I was just talking to another friend of
mine the other day about a pain pills
got addicted.
He was a recovering from a surgery.
They gave him some pain pills and then
he had some complications with the
recovery.
I think it was a.
God damn it,
I can't remember.
It was up near maybe as a knee surgery.
They had to do a re done another
surgery.
They had to go in and because it has
some scar tissue and there's like know
four weeks later they'd go and do
another surgery.
Uh,
they give them more pain pills.
So now he's on pain pills for three
months and then he tries to get off of
him and he says,
yeah,
you have to be taken off of a medical.
You're not supposed to just go cold
Turkey.
Some people do.
But meanwhile no one told him no.
Nobody tells you.
I mean,
told them anything and he's all of a
sudden a heroin addict.
He said,
what in the fuck happened?
I'm an opioid addict.
I had a tooth extracted and they gave me
like,
I don't know,
20 Vicodin,
trust something,
you know,
for the week or something.
And it's like,
it's a tooth.
This done.
I'm going to be okay.
It's going to be sore for a day and I'll
be uh,
but,
but it's what they do.
It's how they write the script and then
you get people who will sell them,
right?
Who will be like,
oh,
I got these pills.
Yeah,
I can just sell them.
I sold mine.
When I had my knee operation I took,
it was either vicodin or percocet.
I can't remember which one it was,
but it made me so fucked up that uh,
I sold them to a friend of mine at the
pool hall,
so I can't take this shit.
I just put me in a coma.
I took back in once and in the same way
I got sick.
I didn't like,
I didn't like the feeling and I didn't
understand why people did exactly.
This is the high you want.
I have a friend who's a musician who is
really creative on Viking and he said he
writes music on Viking and I'm like,
what?
Like what?
He plays classical guitar,
takes Vicodin and just zones out and
writes classical guitar music.
I'm like,
don't get it,
man.
I felt so stupid when I took that.
I didn't,
I didn't like that.
I didn't like that feeling,
but I don't.
Being in a little
pain,
it's like I get it.
I'm hurt.
There is a reason you have pain,
right?
Your body saying,
hey,
some shit's wrong here.
Exactly.
Pay attention to it or don't use this.
Don't use this body part.
Right?
Like if your elbow hurts or something to
your body saying,
okay,
don't use the elbow for a week.
Yeah,
he don't pick that up,
but if you just know,
it's just so
another reason not to be in the NFL.
People just need to be comfortable being
uncomfortable.
Just relax.
Just understand that this is a.
This is gonna make you appreciate the
good times.
Right?
Because like right now you're in a bad
place,
but that doesn't happen.
The moon,
we go a long time ago.
Stan hope.
Did a bit about that.
Write about anything you feel is a drug
for it.
Like any physical or emotional feeling
you have.
I didn't see that drug for.
It's a long time ago.
Yeah,
but he's right.
Anything,
anything.
There's a drug to make it
better.
When I got my nose fixed,
I got a deviated septum operated on.
They pulled out a bunch of scar tissue
and shit,
but I'm telling you there was no pain.
I mean it was uncomfortable for as much
time as they had the packet.
Yeah.
It was packed up with a gauze or these
foam things with tubes hanging out that
dripped like the blood is dripping out
of it.
That was uncomfortable.
But what I mean uncomfortable,
like it doesn't feel good to shove both
fingers up your nose and leave them
there.
I wasn't in pain and my doctor was
pushing the pills on me.
He gave me two different prescriptions
for pain pills for vicodins and I think
of the other ones roxies and I was like,
man,
this doesn't hurt.
And he's like,
well it might hurt later.
I'm like,
how's it going to hurt?
Like what is he going to get?
Something's going to change.
Like,
what's going to change?
Like how's it going to hurt later?
Like right now it's just like my nose
feels uncomfortable.
Like it's not,
it's not painful though.
I just,
I think people just,
you get told by your doctor that you're
going to be in pain and you might be
uncomfortable.
So I have some pills for,
you know,
like Jesus,
I better take these pills for it gets
bad.
I better take these pills before I can't
take it anymore.
And he started freaking out.
I will say this,
I did find out the medical use for
cocaine and it absolutely works numbing.
Yeah.
I had um,
a ripped cornea.
Yeah.
Playing Ball.
This guy finger ripped across and,
and I'm talking the kind of pain where
you just hit the ground,
like you're just done.
Like your body is like,
don't do shit,
you are in May.
And I went to the doctor and that's what
they use.
They put liquid cocaine eye drops in my
eye and the pain disappeared instantly.
I was like,
can I?
And he was like,
no,
we don't prescribe these.
You have to come in and we have to put
them in the eye.
But I will say,
you know how when you go to the doctor
and you're like,
make it better.
Like that's always your dream.
Like just make it better.
So I could leave.
He made it better.
The pain just went away.
They put lidacain up my nose.
When I got the,
um,
the Gaza sucked out,
pull the plugs out and he sprays,
lie to cane up there.
I'm going,
I've had that stuff a couple of times.
One time from a real bad sunburn.
I put Lidacain all over my back and it's
the same feeling.
It's like I'll never,
I'll never do it again.
I'll just take the pain because the
feeling that you get from La to Kansas,
this gross,
weird,
like he feels sketchy.
Like your heart feels sketchy,
like who you feel like you don't want to
eat,
but you know,
you probably should but it's a lie to
king,
gives you a very weird feeling.
And I,
I was eating that night,
I went to a dinner and I was eating at
the steak place and I was like barely
hung.
I'm like,
why do I feel like shit?
And then I realized like,
oh,
they pumped that fucking lie to cane in
my notes.
It went in your system but it wouldn't
use.
I swallowed it could taste it,
could taste it in the back because
they're pumping it up your nose because
I should've just them yank that stuff
out.
Just pull it out because it was really
no big deal,
you know?
But they,
they have you convinced that you're
going to be in agony,
you know?
Yeah.
And different people have different pain
tolerance.
Some people are pussies.
Yeah.
Some people.
Okay.
And then others can,
you know,
can take it.
Well that's the thing about Jujitsu,
Jujitsu,
doing Jujitsu for 20 plus years or
whatever I've done.
You're always in pain.
You just,
you just get used to compartmentalizing
like,
oh my arm's fucked up.
So just accept it and deal with it.
Because if you took a pain pill every
time you were injured from Jujitsu.
Yeah,
you're good on them all junky.
You're going to be a junkie,
you know,
that's why I avoid Jujitsu.
Good.
Good call.
Stay on those days when I used to play
basketball all the time though.
That's the way it was.
It was like my knees always hurt or
something.
Yeah.
Something,
you know.
And the funniest one.
We were in this basketball league and
everyone on my team was like mid
thirties,
you know,
30 to 35,
whatever.
And we were playing these kids,
these kids were like 19,
20 and we walked into the gym and they
go right on the court.
They are running it and our whole team
is sitting there.
You're rapping shit up with tape,
you're rubbing bengay or something,
whatever.
She got like our whole team is on the
bed just warming up like rubbing and
wrapping,
looking at them like,
well we beat them,
you know,
we were veterans,
we knew what we were doing,
but it was such an obvious thing in the
beginning.
Like if Ellis we get notes and now all
of those guys.
So he used to play ball with all play
golf.
Like that's the retired sport if I like
am place playing ball on hard concrete
to like those parts
surfaces.
That shit has got to be terrible for you
all to stop and start and bouncing
around and
well doctors will tell you the nice
aren't made for sports,
you know,
especially not running and jumping
sports.
But when you're,
when you're a kid,
nobody's gonna tell you not to play
ball.
You know what I mean?
Like,
it's funny to me when I'm watching
college basketball and they're like,
these guys are tired.
I'm like,
no,
they're not.
They're 19 and they're playing
basketball.
If they weren't here,
you know where they be playing
basketball at the gym.
So yeah,
there were a lot of things.
They're not tired right now.
They,
they,
you know,
they may have lost concentration.
They made this,
that the other but tired.
You're a 19 year old athlete,
you know,
Kinda shaped those guys.
Like they're not tired.
Well,
basketball on a hardwood floor seems to
be.
It have a little gift.
Yeah.
It's got a little gift to it and you
need.
The shoes are so much better now.
I mean,
you,
you ever put on a pair of converse?
Chuck Taylors?
I wear them all the time.
Imagine playing like imagine running and
jumping in those.
Well there's an argument for you because
you develop,
strengthen your feet like that.
What you're dealing with with these
basketball shoes is essentially like a
big rubber cast and that these rubber
cast and all the cushioning and all that
jazz actually weakens your feet.
I don't buy it because I can't.
I have this one pair of Nike's,
I don't know what they are.
They're air something but they got the
full air so.
And they're the only shoes I can run in.
Right you today.
But you wait,
what?
Two 40 to 50.
Yeah,
but so they make no mistake.
These guys are big.
These guys six,
seven,
200,
200 plus stomping and everything like
that.
I guess like especially you got to
consider basketball players are playing
how many days a week for how many
months?
A year.
I mean and then in the off season and
it's not like they just lay around and
get fat.
Right.
They're worth me also.
And also you've got to look at how much
money is invested in that player.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like you just wanted Russell Westbrook
just sign for 200 and whatever million
dollars.
You better believe his feet are going to
be taken care of.
Like whatever shoes he's playing in are
going to be the best thing possible for
his feet because we've got $40,000,000
a year invested in and gets a contract
like that.
Did the hose just start circling like
paltrow?
No,
they've been there.
They've been there.
You,
you get hoses around way before 2
million.
But once,
once that happens they start thinking
all I need is one sperm to crack the egg
and I'm good.
Right.
There's a lot of gals out there like
that back in.
Okay.
What was it?
80 eight,
89.
I used to play ball at valley college
all the time,
like pick up all.
But it was high level.
There were good,
you know,
I played with guys who had been in like
d one who had played division one league
and stuff like that.
The NBA Rehab was in Van Nuys and on
weekends they would come to the gym and
they play ball with us right now I got
to know a few players and this one guy
told me,
and this was an 80,
like I said,
88,
89.
He said an NBA kid is worth 100 grand a
year for 18 years.
He said,
do use checks,
poke holes in the condoms.
He was like,
you can't trust any of them.
And that was then with that kind of my,
that was back when,
you know,
$5 million was a huge contract.
Right.
You know,
so you can only imagine now because it
seems fairly inexpensive,
will take care of a child.
But again,
in [inaudible] 89,
this was back in [inaudible] 89.
So now that that hundred grand is
probably half a million probably.
Right.
And you look,
I think the,
the average salary in the NBA,
including the guys on the bench is like
two point 3 million.
Isn't that funny too?
Because when you think about like say
the average person makes like what 70
grand,
60 grand a year is that minimum wage?
Not Minimum wage.
Middle class was middle middle class,
like 60,
70 here in California is I think across
America.
I think it's like 40 something so.
But the idea that this baby would live
like that,
it's like,
no,
no.
Like,
you know,
the guy doesn't even know the kid.
Right?
She's taking care of it.
It doesn't even know her.
Like if,
if he has to be child support,
like you're not know you're playing
child support.
Like lavish.
Lavish.
Yeah.
You can't.
You like the average person likes if the
average family is existing off of 50 to
$70,000
a year,
but this woman wants a half a million
for a super baby.
Yeah.
It's fascinating.
Right?
It's like we have these weird rules
like,
well how lean minute,
why is that the case?
Because it's what dad makes right now to
what dad makes.
But I mean you're not asking someone to
pay for the kids living expenses when
you're asking someone to keep.
Keep a kid in the lap of luxury and then
the mom's going to buy a car and and get
her nails did and that's the fight that
dads have.
A lot of the dads were like,
well just send me the bill.
Send me the bill for private school.
What does this here,
Antonio,
how you say his name?
Marty.
Marty just had number 14 is $3 million
dollar deal from the colts and
immediately used it to settle a child
support dispute with a baby mama to
avoid possible arrest in the process.
Cromarty was delinquent on child support
payments to Rosa Meta.
Pierre.
Sounds like a lovely lady.
The mother of Alonzo,
his oldest child,
AK number one of 13 kids.
14 to 14.
Well,
uh,
he was ordered to pay her $4,000
per month.
That's not that bad.
That's actually reasonable.
Now multiply that by 14.
That's a lot.
Tubes tied to the last year.
And I still had a kid.
Damn,
that's some powerful.
I'm gonna.
See what it looks like.
Scroll up.
He's like,
what the fuck?
Uh,
which is why,
you know,
when you get to to captain nick and the
boycott of football and so people are
mad at the players will play in.
It's like that's why you got to play
because you got 14 kids.
Capital boycott of football was like
what?
What does that have to do with
transport?
Meaning that,
um,
the,
the idea of black people boycotting
football and then people saying like,
why did the players play like,
you know,
screw them,
but everybody,
every black player,
the nfl just refused to play.
Like,
no,
that ain't gonna happen.
They need their paychecks.
This whole national anthem thing along
football is very weird.
It's like football players should be
playing football.
UFC fighters don't have to fucking stand
there with their hand over their heart
to show allegiance and to show you know
what you're,
you're basically asking someone to be
domesticated.
You're asking them to follow the rules.
The truth has come out like players
didn't do it until I was it 10 years ago
or something like that.
When the,
when the government started paying the
NFL to have them do it because it's,
yeah,
this,
that whole thing.
It's weird,
man.
It's weird because the whole thing
you're asking them to be,
you know,
they have to,
to give in,
you know,
that you're,
you're asking them to follow the rule.
He,
my,
my problem with it and I called it the
misdirection.
The protest never had to do with the
flag.
It was about the protests had to do with
cops and the treatment and it was just,
he just did it at that point because
that's a powerful statement to do it at
that point,
you know,
and,
and now the misdirection to changing up
the topic is making it about the flag
and it's like,
no,
that's not what they are.
They will never protesting the flag or
veterans or,
or Americans or and,
and again,
when you get into those rules of the
flag,
you're not supposed to have the flag on
tee shirts or bikinis or hats or,
or a million other things we sell with
the flag on it.
Like if you want to talk about
respecting the flag,
we wouldn't do any of that.
You summed it up.
I mean it is,
it's about control,
right?
It's the same thing with these freedom
of speech marches.
Like where?
Yeah,
it's okay to have freedom of speech as
long as you're saying something I agree
with.
Right.
But the problem with this whole
kaepernick thing and said it's not an
effective form of protest too because
it's getting people pissed off for the
wrong reasons.
Well,
it was people thinking that you're,
you're protesting America itself,
why don't you move to Canada and then
people start getting crazy about it,
but to set what he's trying to do or
what he was trying to do was protest all
these unarmed people getting shot by
cops and so he takes a need for that.
But the national anthem doesn't have
shit to do with those cops.
Well,
it just became a thing of when one guy
did it and he did it as a protest and he
said he wanted to start the conversation
and then the conversation got lost and
now the conversation is completely lost.
Then the argument is a completely
different topic and you know that.
But yeah,
what you said control is definitely part
of it.
Same thing with the universities,
right?
With free speech on the universities and
you know when you look at a school like
Berkeley,
Berkeley had a reasonable arguments like
look,
when we bring one of these radical
speakers here and it costs a million
dollars for security,
who's going to pay that?
So like we,
if you're going to pay it,
fine,
we'll let you talk,
but if nobody's going to pay the million
dollars for security and we can't have
these radical speakers here,
sort of,
you know,
the problem with that article is they've
had those speakers there forever and
then when they started having these
antifa protests and they also start
supporting these antifa protests,
that's a big issue.
Well,
they stopped having cops go after the
Antifa people and the Berkeley,
the literally the chief of police was
literally telling people the mayor was
telling the police to stand down and let
these people protest and not just
protests.
They were being very violent and
attacking things.
And you're setting up a reaction action
event,
right?
So if you have something like that where
people are breaking windows and light
things on fire or doing whatever they're
doing,
you're going to have people that say
fuck,
those people were going to meet there
and we're going to protest the anti
protest people.
And then next thing you know you've got
a real issue in your hand.
But that's the point.
That's,
that's where we're at now,
where everything has to be that big an
issue.
You're right.
Twenty years ago,
10 years ago at Berkeley,
you could have had a speaker,
a right wing speaker that the school
didn't agree with.
It would have been some protesters
outside just not even two years ago,
but then it became,
and this,
this is a social media effect,
right?
The speaker brings his social media
thing and he needs to stir it up to
build his social media side and then
some people come and then the other side
gets mad just what you said,
and they bring their and then you bring
the angry groups from both sides are
going to meet and then they're like,
okay,
now it's because it makes the whole
thing,
but it's like promoting a fight.
You know what I mean?
It's like promoting a fight.
It's like it's one thing if two guys get
into a fight,
but if you promote that fight for a
month,
three months,
six months ahead,
that fight is going to be huge and this
is the same thing.
They promote these speakers.
The,
the,
the protest is part of the publicity,
right?
You know,
so well their speakers and then there's
people that are provocateurs,
right?
Like,
you know,
Milo unit,
that's a better term.
So I shouldn't say speakers.
I should say provocateurs.
Shapiro is a speaker,
Ben Shapiro's and intellectual and he's
a guy.
He's got.
Some are very solid arguments whether
you agree with them or not.
He's,
he's got some real facts to go with his
arguments and they were,
he's a junior whereas a yarmulke and
people calling them a Nazi,
like it's like this whole punch Nazis
thing and getting it.
I mean just the,
the arguments are getting so blurry and
it's just like we were talking about
before.
When it comes to gun control,
it's teams you're on.
I'm on team left wing,
I support Antifa.
You know,
I'm on team right wing.
I support the Conservatives and Potus,
like the people that are calling trump
potus,
you know,
you are defaming potus.
Like,
Whoa,
what's fucking trump?
It's Donald Trump.
If there's ever an argument,
this is ridiculous.
The fucking a guy who was the host of
the apprentice is now the guy you're
calling Joe Joe.
You're disrespecting the White House
differences.
Disrespectful,
potents.
I mean it's like literally like the
pope.
He gets to this almost like paypal
situation.
Right.
And again,
these are the same people who said the
same thing about Barack Obama.
Yeah.
You know,
last year.
Right.
But the president has never been
disgraced or insulted.
Like really they insulted when he wore
tennis shoes.
We played that when Obama was 10.
So that was the end of America with
respect to the office for off color
clothing.
It's a gang color.
And then Michelle Obama wore sleeveless
dress and I think,
I think that was just,
you know,
didn't Alex Jones do something recently
saying that Michelle Obama was a man,
like proof that Michelle Obama was a
man.
Fuck,
he's on some shit today.
They'll do all that shit with Michelle
ain't in the room.
Yeah,
exactly.
No,
no.
It was easy to put down with trump to
call pro football players.
Sons of bitches from Huntsville,
Alabama.
Yeah.
Let's try it on the sideline.
Right?
A few of them standing next to you,
sons of bitches.
Yeah,
fire the sons of bitches.
You're fired.
They shouldn't have them fucking stand
for the national anthem.
First of all,
if you want to have a national anthem
for a game,
what are you saying?
Are you.
I mean,
is this.
you're,
you're rallying up patriotism at a
sporting event.
Sporting events are supposed to be
entertaining.
It's supposed to remove us from all of
our daily bullshit,
right?
If it's going to be entertaining,
be entertaining,
and they did they.
Sorry.
I mean it's okay.
They did a thing this past week at the
rams game.
During the national anthem.
How many people were in the beer line?
How many guys were taking a piss?
Oh yeah.
How many you need?
You know what I mean?
It's not like those guys not taking.
Everybody stopped anyway.
It's like,
you know,
not like everybody stopped and turned
and held their hand over their heart.
Like,
yeah,
well I got my Dick in my hand.
Literally literally into the bathroom
between people's assets for pissing
during the national anthem.
If you tell them they can,
it's just the protest is ineffective,
right?
Getting on your knees,
we.
It just causes too much controversy and
here's the other problem with it.
It doesn't stop anything.
It doesn't stop coc cops or do anything.
It doesn't even shed light on it.
It just points to you and people start
talking about,
well,
what is it that you're protesting?
Well we're,
we're mad at you because you're not
standing up for the national anthem.
It creates all this noise.
And again,
that's the part I called the
misdirection because initially when
Kaepernick did it,
it had some meaning.
It had some meaning to him and it was
about starting a conversation and when
it became this bigger thing like you're
talking about when it became this,
Oh,
you're anti American,
your impact troops or blah blah,
blah.
Now it's lost its effectiveness.
Now.
Yeah,
you got to do something else because
that doesn't it.
You're right.
It doesn't mean anything anymore.
People don't even know.
They don't even know why you're doing
it,
but they hate you for doing it.
Like doing it now too.
Why are you doing it?
I do it because I hate puppies.
Yeah,
exactly.
Fuck is everybody's doing it because
they're mad at trump.
Shit about the NFL.
So you're getting just giant groups of
people doing it now.
Much more so than before.
Yeah.
And it's,
yeah,
it's,
it's lost,
its effectiveness,
its losses,
importance,
and you know,
and the players,
a lot of the players get caught in the
middle,
right?
Because if you do have a thing where
your team says you can't do it or you're
going to be fined or you're going to
whatever.
The NBA said that it's against the
rules,
the MBA,
the MBA.
So not anybody doing that in the NBA
yet.
Uh,
they,
well they hadn't started playing.
The NBA just started this week in
preseason before it started,
before,
in the past the NBA did things like they
warn 'em I can't breathe t shirts and
they've done things like that.
NBA players,
NBA players are a bit more sophisticated
and their protests.
And I think there are also a more united
let's head trauma,
you know?
Yeah.
Probably a big part of it.
They've also been encouraged,
I think,
to speak out,
whereas I don't know that the nfl
players are also encouraged to speak out
in public.
I don't know if topics,
I don't know,
basketball players with necessarily
encouraged to speak out or the big
difference with the NBA,
the players have bigger than the team.
Right,
right,
right.
They're huge fan.
Huge stars.
Yeah.
So you have like Lebron is bigger than
the cavaliers.
Curry is bigger than the warriors.
When we did you bomb at the president,
I was like,
oh my goodness.
Like where are we?
Where are we going with it?
We're a fucking superstar.
Pro Athlete is tweeting you bomb at the
president of the United States who
happens to be a reality show host.
Fuck man,
this is good.
Theoretically,
you know,
look,
we've elected a reality show host
Lebraun could be the president in 20
years.
One hundred percent vice president,
Kanye,
vice president,
conduit with the fucking Prozac drip.
He would have an IV bag drip and right
into his art.
My stand there,
like zoning out,
getting Chubby.
Dashing is shinnecock dash first lady.
Whoa,
why not?
Why not?
Why the hell?
Not that Melania can barely speak
English.
They're talking about immigration.
So closing the border like,
what the fuck?
Where'd you get her?
She doesn't speak and she did lesbian
porn.
I don't watch out.
Oh,
watch bill Maher all the time.
But apparently he did this sub kind of
top 10 list about Melania and if one of
the jokes was she has no
first language.
Yeah,
that's a joke that Russell Peters said
about Yoshi,
Yoshi Kobiashi Shit.
He was saying.
He goes,
ah,
he goes,
Yoshi speaks terrible English.
But when you talk to people that speak
Japanese is Japanese sucks too.
It's like you have no real language.
Yeah,
it's the whole thing is,
is this football thing is very strange.
It's very strange because now they're,
they kicked these two high school kids
right off the team because they're
following their heroes.
So they say,
fuck it,
I'm going to take a knee to.
First of all,
you'd taken a knee.
You should at least be able to write an
essay.
Tell me why you're taking a nice son.
You know,
and you got to know the difference
between Your y o u r and while you
apostrophe r e and you also got to be
starting.
Yes.
You know what I mean?
Like,
like if the starting quarterback takes a
knee,
he does a lot more latitude than,
you know,
a second string defensive end.
You know what I mean?
Like,
you know,
if trust me,
if,
uh,
you know,
Aaron Rodgers,
if Dak Prescott was taken a knee,
this be a whole different conversation.
What?
Kaepernick wasn't a big star player.
He was,
but he fell off.
He fell off because of the controversy
and all the halo.
I don't know what it was he,
he had,
he had started falling off before that
so that we know what it was.
I,
yeah.
I don't know what I mean.
But one of the arguments is in,
it is true.
He's a lot better than a lot of
quarterbacks who have jobs.
See that was the thing.
They said no,
it's not a conspiracy because of the
protests.
But then they showed the numbers of like
various backup quarterbacks who were in
the league and he's better than a lot of
them and in one of the owners,
I think it was Baltimore where the coach
wanted him and the owner was like,
Nah,
I don't want him because of the protest.
So it became a thing of where they said,
they said he's not blackballed because
of the protest,
but then it came out.
Yeah,
he was blackballed because of the
protest.
And again that that's one of those
things where,
and you know this with any athlete,
like your complaints depend on where you
are in your career.
Sure.
Tom Brady even said the president was
divisive and when Tom Brady said that
everybody went,
oh Jesus.
Right,
right.
It's not taking the knee yet,
but they're,
they're hooking arms.
Yeah.
Everybody's arms in unity.
Because when trump spoke out against the
nfl,
now he,
he's aiming at their money.
Yeah.
You know,
when he's telling fans not to go to the
games,
like those owners love him,
but now they're like,
whoa,
hold the fuck up now.
Yeah.
That's money out of our pocket.
Everybody saying hold the fuck up now
because it is working.
Direct TV just offered this gigantic
refund for their nfl package because
people are pissed off that people are
taking a knee.
You're paying to see football.
You fucks.
You're not paying to see people stand
with their hand over their heart.
Like what?
Here's the here's the solution.
Take all that shit out of the game.
If you want the players to be compliant
and submissive when you're.
You're asking the wrong thing.
You're talking about super athletes is a
what is essentially a group combat
sport.
That's a football.
Yes.
Okay,
and if they're not,
I mean,
what are you doing here?
You're.
You're telling them to keep their job.
They have to put their hand over their
heart and standards.
Certain position.
That seems very fucking bizarre.
Fox Fox said that they're going to stop
televising the national anthem and it
was pointed out.
Well you didn't use to televise the
national anthem like you.
You didn't tell buys it until two
weeks ago when it became controversial.
Before that you will be listening to
those three guys in the studio right up
til the kickoff.
You and then the only time they televise
it it if it was like Whitney Houston was
singing it where it was.
That was a big deal.
So.
Well,
I'm a big fan of no anthem in sports
because I like sports to be split.
Like one of the things I love about the
UFC,
so there's no national anthems you don't
have to play.
Do they often say the Brazilian national
anthem when Josie,
all those fighting or the American
national anthem.
When Chris Weidman's fighting,
you don't have to do that.
They just go right to the fight.
Here's the main event of the evening,
boom,
entertainment,
blah,
blah blah,
and if someone wants to make some sort
of a political statement or stand,
they can do that in an interview.
That interview will be judged based on
the content of whatever the conversation
is and that's how it should be.
This weird sort of way where someone
taking a knee is supposed to protest
cops shooting people,
but it doesn't say that while you're
taking the knee,
you're taking a knee during the anthem.
The anthem is supposed to be all of us.
It's supposed to be America,
but then again as a team like the United
States of America,
not the seahawks versus the dolphins.
Put all that aside for a second.
We're all in this together.
That's the idea.
I understand why he did it and I
understand why he did it then because it
was the way to call attention to it,
but now that's lost.
But you know what the national anthem
has been historically.
Get to your seat.
The game's about to start [inaudible].
That's all it was.
Yeah.
It was like the to the.
What's the last word in the last two
words are the national anthem play ball.
Like that's literally,
that's what we thought was part of the
song because that's what you heard
right?
At the end,
the empire Yo play ball and the game
starts,
you know,
so I understood what captain nick did,
but now it's done.
And now it's been compromised and
changed and the arguments changed and,
and yeah,
it's,
you know,
and he's still not playing.
People are using the land of the free to
shake there dick as they like.
What is this just came out now,
uh,
this afternoon,
maybe even within the hour that 1200
players,
personal data has been exposed and
eleague by hackers nfl,
including Colin Kaepernick's data.
What kind of data,
uh,
personal information off of a server
from the NFL,
PA is associated with that.
How was that a hack there?
Or did they just have experience equifax
or whatever.
So they had a bitcoin ransom.
They were trying to say they would,
uh,
get rid of this leak.
But,
uh,
it is now coming out only 428 bucks at
the time.
How crazy is that though?
Give you 400,
28 bucks.
I know someone that happened up to that
bitcoin has really?
Yeah.
I was just talking to her this weekend.
She has an accounting company and
apparently these hackers take control of
your database and they have an
encryption key and you have to pay them
in Bitcoin to get the encryption key to
get back your own data.
Giant group of people from other
countries that engage in this and they,
they target large businesses and people
that will be willing to pay.
Yeah,
I'd like an extortion thing.
Yeah.
Very weird.
So you know,
you have something to lose.
You know me.
If you want to hold my full 128
followers hostage.
Go ahead.
I'll just start another website.
You think Colin Kaepernick gets
confronted by the suits?
Do you think they sit him down and go,
hey man,
you gotta stop doing this.
This is fucking up.
Everybody in.
I think they did last year.
What do you think they did last year?
Where do you think this goes?
I guess my question is like when the
more trump tweets about this ratings
down,
Ella Nfl,
bad,
sad,
you know,
he tweets that and all the trumpets go
along with it and then they start
boycotting.
People are.
I see all these fucking tweets,
boycott the NFL and all this crazy
thing,
you know,
where it goes,
it goes nowhere because we have no
attention span is a nation,
but it's going to have to stop or
continue.
But again,
this is the thing,
we,
we just had this mass shooting so the
attention now will be on,
on the NRA and you know,
guns and,
and so,
you know what I mean?
And the NFL will be on the back burner
like we have you in the past month,
six weeks.
Confederate statues,
right?
Yeah.
Hurricanes,
Charlotesville.
Uh,
yeah.
the NFL,
now it's a mass shooting,
you know what I mean?
We have no,
we have no attention span as a nation,
so it will just go away and,
and in another month people will be
watching football.
There'll be something else.
Yeah.
Because there's always,
there's always the latest big story.
And then that still,
you know,
I haven't heard a thing about a
confederate statue in the last two weeks
with him getting knocked down,
have them getting put back up or
whatever.
You know what I mean?
It's so true,
right.
Wrong or indifferent,
America has zero attention span.
Yeah.
Did you see what that fucking lady from
CBS,
that top executive,
she was like a vice president at cvs,
some huge position.
She went on facebook saying she didn't
feel bad for the people that got shot in
Vegas because they were Republicans.
They were likely Republicans.
She's talking about hundreds of people
that got shot for going to a country
music concert.
Like the fact that she just made this
blanket statement.
She thought they were likely Republicans
because they were at a country music
concert.
You know the thing about that this,
and this is the thing about freedom of
speech that people forget you have
freedom of speech,
but there's consequences,
right?
It's not freedom of speech without
consequence.
So she can say that and then if CBS
fires her the next day,
it's like,
well,
you shouldn't have said that shit.
You know you represent.
Should've kept it to yourself or you
should have told your friends at the
cocktail party,
but the minute you made that public
statement,
we don't want to be associated with you,
but it's what we're talking about
earlier,
this team thing that someone could be so
ideologically isolated,
they're so locked into this liberal
bubble that they think it's okay to say
something like that,
that it's okay for mass murder to exist
and you don't feel bad for those massive
because you don't agree with them
politically or your team ideology.
I mean,
what did you.
Is that.
What is her name?
This lady.
It's fucking insane.
This level.
She was a very high level executive.
This isn't like some new sentences was.
Yeah,
almost.
She's fuck now.
I mean,
she's likely fucked forever.
this is not something that people
forget.
What did.
She was a vice president of business
affairs.
Oh No,
they.
Yeah,
the vice president of business affairs.
Yeah.
Hailey gift them and gold wrote on her
facebook page.
She was not sympathetic to victims of
shootings because she claimed most
country music fans.
Republicans.
Wow.
She wrote that.
If they wouldn't do anything when
children were murdered,
I have no hope that repugnant will ever
do the right thing.
I'm actually not even sympathetic
because country music fans are often a
republican gun toters.
Holy Shit.
You got the right to say it and you've
got the right to lose your job.
Not sympathetic is such A.
I mean that could have been your sister,
your mom,
your daughter,
someone's little kid.
I mean that was a country music thing,
right?
It was a lot of family type folks that
are there.
Country Music events.
Man.
I don't know what time of night that it
all went down,
but how old are you?
10 tall kid in one of those videos.
Yeah,
I mean,
sure,
there's,
there's music things that.
What I,
what I said was,
had it been a rap concert,
they would have blamed the artists.
Not if a white guy did it,
they would have been some serious calls
of,
of horrific racism.
It's just lucky that a white guy was
shooting white people,
you know,
because then again,
it's the reason I laugh because like,
that's how horrific we become as a
society,
that that's the statement.
Like,
you know,
you know what I mean?
Like yeah,
we'll lose a white guy shooting white
people.
So we couldn't twist the race into it,
you know,
you know what I mean?
Like today about someone was writing
about white privilege,
right?
We're,
we're.
So,
we're insane.
We're insane that,
that,
that is the issue with something like
this,
you know,
but,
but it's,
it's true.
I mean what you're saying is true,
but we've reached that level of insanity
that,
that statement is true.
Can Imagine how freaked out people would
be if that was a Muslim that did this.
Oh,
okay.
It'd be war.
What would be war war?
It will be war in the streets.
And,
and you know,
actually like no Muslim would be safe in
America.
I mean is,
are we going to have war on white dudes
with guns?
No,
no.
I mean there was white dudes with guns.
They got shot by white dude with guns.
Everyone must feel so,
so conflicted because a lot of those
people that were in the audience,
like one of the country music guys
actually came out and said that he
completely switched his stance on gun
rights.
He said,
I've been a second amendment advocate my
entire life.
He goes,
I have concealed carry permits.
Uh,
there's people that were concealed carry
permits that were all my staff.
Yeah.
Guitarists.
Las Vegas controlled,
changed his mind and gun control.
What is his name?
Caleb keeter.
Sounds like the widest fucking do that's
ever lived.
Caleb,
good old boy.
My Caleb,
Caleb,
Katie.
I'm going to go out on a limb here and
say Caleb cute drives the truck.
Oh,
for sure.
You have a basketball or a baseball hat
or a cowboy hat leveled 95 wizard
guitarist for the.
What does that Josh Abbott Band see?
I'll say something like that.
I'm like,
who the fuck are they?
And then you go to their twitter page.
They have $24 million followers.
I'm like,
what is happening?
I don't understand.
Country Music is a whole different
world,
different world,
but again,
we're getting back to where we started,
which is great and the insanity of of
the whole thing,
but the problem,
what you said about like a white guy
doing this shooting,
we were talking about everyone's in
their team,
right?
Everyone's in their group,
but this ruins the narrative,
right?
Because if our narrative is the Muslims
are terrorists,
they write today,
they are the terrorists and the black
people are criminals and the Mexicans
are rapists and dope dealers and
everything.
Then,
Oh shit,
one of ours did it to us.
A millionaire.
Yeah.
A white millionaire real estate investor
and a gambler.
This,
this ruins your narrative.
Now you have to.
Now you have to figure out how to change
your story to make him other.
Because he has to somehow become other.
There are people that are taken
advantage of it.
I saw this article on white privilege.
They're saying that the shooter had
white privilege and using his white
privilege.
That's how he walked through the casino
with all these guns and all this
equipment and shit like that.
I'm like,
what is a psychopath?
I believe white privilege exists in
certain circumstances.
Not In that one.
Yeah.
That's a ridiculous argument.
What are we looking at,
Jamie?
Oh,
white privilege of the loan.
Roofshoot all that fucking guy.
Of course.
That fucking fake black guy.
This of course it's Tim who writes that
that guy is such a race.
Oh,
you talking about the article about the
guy being a lone wolf?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I read that.
This whole thing that we're dealing with
as so many different facets to it,
the mass shooter
thing,
but a big part of it is the fact that it
become the narrative for the entire
country.
It becomes a huge part of what
everybody's talking about.
These people that have,
for whatever reason,
they have this need to be a guy who gets
paid attention to this.
This gets back to your point about
mental health and our mental health as a
nation.
That the mass shooter is a thing,
you know,
like,
um,
I think it was trevor Noah was talking
about on the daily show where we're
really not surprised anymore because
he's,
he said he's been in the United States
for two years living in New York for two
years and how many mass shootings is and
it's like,
but Americans are like,
yeah,
you know,
another one.
And we,
we,
we got to develop some sense of outrage
before we do something about this.
Or like the onion article was talking
about we just like,
well,
we'll just hope that it doesn't happen
again.
We won't do anything differently,
right?
We're not going to do anything
different,
but we're just going to hope,
you know,
and that,
and that line.
The thoughts and prayers line.
Stop it,
stop it,
stop it.
Your thoughts and prayers go out to no,
you need to say something.
Right?
And,
and people do.
But if you're,
if you're in the government,
if you're a policy maker than you do
more than just say that you gotta you
gotTa,
you know,
put your balls on the line and step up
and do something challenged.
Challenge the gun lobby about
registration of weapons.
It was easier for them to challenge the
hotel lobby about security and hotels
than the challenge.
The gun lobby about registration or
weapon registration of weapons.
This guy had these weapons illegally.
I mean,
these are still,
at the end of the day,
you're talking about criminal possessing
criminal weapons.
Same thing.
Sandy Hook,
he got hooked.
He got them from his mom.
Got Him legally.
Right?
But he got it.
But you can still make it,
like you said,
if you made it more difficult.
If you had to take a class,
if you had to register,
if you had to be a percentage,
there'd be a percentage that didn't,
didn't have.
Um,
yeah.
I mean your shit should be locked up.
I mean,
it's just.
I just don't know.
But what's interesting too is that trump
used to be a democrat.
A Democrat forever trumps a publicity
guy.
And you know what I mean?
And,
and he,
you know,
this is,
this goes back to Sarah Pailin,
right?
Like I never liked Sarah Palin or agreed
with Sarah Pailin,
but I respected Sarah Pailin,
his ability to manipulate the media.
Sarah Pailin knew how to keep her name
in the news,
you know,
uh,
Kim Kardashians and other one,
like you may not like Kim Kardashian,
but guess what,
you know who she is,
you know who she is.
We all know who she is.
I read somewhere that she is the most
famous woman on earth and I can believe
that.
And I had a whole bit about how the
whole bit about aliens come down here
and try to figure out why that's the
most woman on earth.
And we explained to her by using Oj
Simpson at the whole idea is that Oj
Simpson,
you know,
got out of the Robert Kardashian was Oj
Simpson.
One of his attorneys.
They all died of cancer.
Yeah,
that's what's fucked up.
Yeah.
Athlete Bailey's the only guy that's
alive and he's broke and living in Maine
somewhere.
Everybody that got Oj off it just
ostracized and Johnnie Cochran died of
cancer and died of cancer and they all
just stop.
Fuck hitting team their way.
A lot of the brothers in jail because
Johnny Cochran died.
Joe,
I ain't gonna lie to you Joe.
We Miss Johnny.
He fucked up with doj was good.
The glove does not fit.
You must acquit.
And everybody was like,
why is a lot of ball players doing time
saying damn Johnny,
are you.
So you watched that whole Cuba gooding
jr thing.
I've only watched one episode.
I watched one episode last night,
but it brought it all back.
Underrated actor.
Oh yeah.
He was wanting to ask her.
Yeah,
I know.
But then sort of dropped off.
Yeah.
You look at.
And in that movie he did with the narrow
about being the first black driver.
He was a man of honor,
who is a phenomenal movie.
Do you ever see that movie?
No,
I never even heard of it.
Yeah,
it's,
I'm,
I'm pretty sure it's called man of honor
or something.
Cuba gooding jr place the first black
deep sea diver.
And it's true story.
Yeah.
A man of honor,
2000,
check that out.
He sort of dropped off in a weird way.
Like wonder what happened with him.
I don't know.
It's one of those things when he gets a
chance to play a role,
he's phenomenal in it.
But so many times he gets these clown
movies,
bullshit rolls and stuff like that.
I don't,
I don't know how Hollywood works on that
level,
so I don't know what,
what it is.
But uh,
the thing is some poor choices,
poor choices.
After a.
What was the fucking agent movie?
Show me the money.
Fuck Jerry Mcguire Mcguire.
After that movie there was a big drop
off.
It happens to you,
you know?
Same thing happened with a Jamie Foxx.
Jamie Foxx is still in the Max.
He still does everything.
I mean,
he was in the ward.
He was great in Django and that baby
baby driver.
I didn't see that one.
I heard it was amazing.
Yeah,
it's great movie.
It was good.
Met Jamie Foxx is just one of those
weird dudes.
It seems like he could do anything.
Super talent.
Yeah,
super personable too.
That's the other thing about them is
such a normal guy.
Met Him last year,
couldn't have been nicer.
He was very cool.
Yeah.
He did the podcast a couple months ago.
It's normal was company.
There's a recent clip of him describing
the potential Tyson movie that that
might be making and like the opening of
it that they might have worked out.
It's fucking.
It's like a three minute clip of him
just describing it during a little tyson
impression in there.
Oh,
well he can really
amazing impressions.
He would be great as Tyson just have to
to a lot of roids yeah.
He's gonna have to get real quick bail.
Completely different body types anyway.
To have to actually learn how to box.
I don't know if he does,
but if you can't have a guy like you
might have trained some.
When he did Ali,
who was.
He was what?
Ali's corner man when I'm.
Will Smith Played Ali.
Wasn't he Bundini Brown?
Yeah,
he was.
he will.
Smith pulled it off.
He looked like a boxer.
He looked like he had been training,
but there's a few guys that you don't.
So yeah,
there is a.
yeah,
there's a few guys that just don't pull
it off.
The,
the,
when you're playing a fighter,
like even Russell Crowe,
when he played Jim Braddock is like not
buying.
You imagine if boxing really was like
movie fights where every punch connects.
Well,
some fights are go watch a turtle Gotti
versus Micky Ward.
Those fucking fights.
Literally we're movie fights.
That's what everybody was so jazzed up
about some of the most.
I mean blood and guts fights for sure,
but preposterous fights and stood right
in front of each other and beat the shit
out of each other.
That was um,
Hagler hearns.
That was the only fight I saw that,
that was a movie for like,
yeah,
we're just gonna stand here and just
punch each other until it's over.
Just decided that that fight.
He mean he fought very strategically and
most fights,
you know,
when he fought Mugabi with Gabi was a
murderous puncher and he took Mugabi in
the deep water and then fucked him up
and stopped him.
But not earns.
He said I'm going to jump right in your
face,
motherfucker.
They didn't like each.
No,
they didn't.
They didn't break his hand like that to
keep punching.
He broke his hand on his head and he
heard haggler yeah.
He stunned Hagler in the first round.
But hagler had a preposterous chin.
Postrace he's only knocked down.
His entire career was a bullshit knocked
down.
I for get who was it?
Knocked him down.
But uh,
some Argentinian dude,
but it was a bullshit.
Knocked down,
was a fake,
knocked out.
Was like a slip.
And then he moved to Italy and started
making movies.
Just banging Italian tricks.
If you go to Italy,
man,
I know you realize.
You're like,
why am I trying so hard?
Very big.
Came down.
Yeah.
The Night Marvin Hagler was not knocked
down.
They should.
That's a fucking stain on his record,
man.
That should go back and remove that.
It was not a knock down.
You can see that car.
They got to play it.
Play it.
Let's watch.
Oh,
see if you could find that the knockdown
in some bullshit fucking knocked down.
They don't have a clip of role.
Dan Knocking Down Marvin Hagler.
Marvin hadn't still beat his ass.
He had um,
ridiculous muscles on the side of his
head that was like,
he was built with like,
he was born with my gear temples.
They said the,
the muscles that surrounded his temples
were three times larger than a normal
person's.
Oh,
that happens,
right?
Certainly.
Yeah,
for sure man.
Some guys have bigger dicks.
Yeah.
Just show it real quick.
Let's see here.
Pull shit knocked down.
I mean he just like pushed down the back
of his head that they're going to show
it the.
Oh,
they're going to show it in between
rounds.
Yeah.
Just let it go for a second here.
What'd you do?
I just want to show just in between
rounds,
they'll show it on the replay.
So went back to his corner,
48 Kaos and he's 62 fights and he's one
of the few guys that when he lost to
sugar ray Leonard and he just went,
fuck this.
And I don't think he lost that fight.
I've watched that fight a few times.
I thought it was a decision for hire.
Should have been a decision for how to
look at this.
See this totally slipped.
Total slip.
He's.
He mostly missed the punch.
The Punch.
Let's see.
He just kind of pushed him down with his
forearm and Hagler bounced right up.
That is not a knockdown you mother
fuckers.
But he took some bombs from Mugabe.
Mugabe was murdering people at the time,
but you know,
we're were talking about football
players.
Boxers is another one where they don't
know when to let it go.
Yeah.
Like you got,
you got.
You can only take so many punches to the
hit.
Yeah.
Well,
and then they find it as well.
Chocolate Dell's talking about making a
comeback.
Now you get hooked on the fame,
but you gotta at some point you got to
the end.
It's not even when they get old,
it's when they get to like 50,
like late forties,
50 unique in that.
I mean the dells talking about making a
comeback now at 48 and I think he's been
out of the fight game for at least five
or six years.
The UFC gave him a no,
I'm like sort of a no show job for
awhile and they said,
look,
you don't have to work.
He just come in and do some events every
now and then you get a chunk of money
every month and so he was living off
that and doing really well with that,
but then the UFC sold and when the UFC
sold,
they killed those jobs.
This whole fucking ufc sold things so
crazy because they bought it for
$4,000,000,000.
Billion like to make the monthly nut.
They had to cut 100 jobs from the UFC.
100 people got fired and now they gotta
they gotta figure out some way to.
Well,
it's not just that,
it's like you gotta you gotta make
payments every month.
So they sold some more of it off.
They sold some more of the assets off to
some other corporations or some other
people and I'm glad I don't have to deal
with that shit dude.
I just show up and talk.
I don't know.
I don't envy the people that have to
deal with the bean counters.
What?
I mean,
what is worth $4,000,000,000?
Zero wars.
Yes.
Yeah.
You can just say it and,
and it was like worth it.
Yeah.
Like I bought star wars for
$4,000,000,000
and I'm making money.
Yeah,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
Disney bought that,
but then they put star wars rides and
like absolute shit.
Disney,
you know,
you can you ever do get charged towards
judge our
banks to come to your birthday party?
I bet there's a whole team of them
probably.
Have you done that ride at Disneyland
was the last time you've been at
Disneyland?
Sit down that ride.
You go there.
It's like a virtual identities here.
Star Wars.
Right?
That ride is awesome.
Yeah.
I mean,
again,
it's when Disney does something,
they're going to do it right.
The movies like the,
they're not going to be any more of
those banks movies or any of that.
Like this.
And he's like,
yeah,
we were going to handle this.
Yeah.
That guy didn't work out.
He's still,
he's in the uh,
the Star tours movie though.
Yeah.
That thing,
the little thing where sometimes you run
into him like underwater is driving and
everybody gets excited,
but it's a.
But the quality of movies went back up.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
You know,
they don't play games.
Yeah,
a lot of money invested.
They're doing a star wars park at
Disneyland.
Yeah,
some gigantic fucking.
He was a.
It was what was it used to be called
tomorrow land or something like that was
something else.
And they're converting it and making the
whole star wars.
Yeah.
They said it's going to be opening like
two years.
It's going to be insane.
I don't know how old you are,
but do you remember when the first movie
came?
So yeah.
You remember when the first movie came
out?
Fuck yeah.
Like,
like think about that when think about
George Lucas,
like I'm gonna make a movie that's going
to change culture.
It is literally gonna Bring Lang like
change language.
Like we're going to have,
you know,
things we talk about,
right?
Like Jedi mind tricks and force.
And it's got to be mind boggling to sit
back and say,
yeah,
I created this whole thing.
Got to be mind boggling,
but do you think he set out to do that
to me?
He set out to just make.
No,
he just set out to make a great movie
and all the buttons for people.
Everything for for generations and
generations to be like,
you know,
he does all the things.
He had the rebel with the fucking giant
gorilla that followed them around the
gun wise.
Yoda,
Yoda.
He had the old man who is the master
who's showing them how to do it in the
master dies.
None of the greatest villains of all
time.
The best guy who killed people.
His mind.
Yeah.
Any.
Any fucking you didn't see his eyes,
couldn't see anything.
No emotion.
He just,
yeah,
he just,
he would breathe.
He would.
That was the shit and imagined being a
storm trooper.
Just an average storm trooper and you
hear this coming down the hall,
you're like,
Oh shit,
I might die.
Like I don't know if I did my job right,
but maybe he just needs to make an
example.
Try watching it today though.
So it's not it,
but it still,
it's only still great because it,
it brings back the memory of how great
it was,
but no,
it's not the movie it was then,
but we'd never seen anything like that
jump into hyperspace.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
The special effects were terrible.
Did you ever see,
um,
dark theater with the actor's voice?
The actual actor?
No.
Yeah,
you can see it on youtube.
Exactly.
Well,
not exactly because you know,
the actor had to do the lines.
That's not quite the impact of James
Earl Jones,
James Earl Jones voice.
That guy has ving.
Rhames is the modern,
the modern version that ving rhames has
a lot a voice in the UFC and tell you
to,
you're talking to a guy with a voice who
can't get a job because those guys do
it.
Yeah.
Because I lost one to Danny Glover and
I'm like,
if I ever meet,
but I'm like,
man,
you got lethal weapon money.
A Guinness beer commercial.
I needed that competition out there bro.
And nobody's gonna lay down for you.
Nobody at work.
Especially not in the voiceover.
I got to start punching people in the
throat.
The voice over games.
A weird game.
Right.
There's some dudes like,
you know,
who is an interesting one is uh,
the guy from Ray Donovan.
Fuck's his name?
Schreiber.
Lave.
Do you say it live?
Live Schreiber.
But he's really good at it.
He does a lot of the UFC wants for Fox
and um,
I can never remember his name,
but um,
Donald Sutherland.
Oh yeah.
He's the voice of Delta Boys.
He's the voice of juice because he know.
Is it Donald Sutherland?
Am I saying that right?
It's at the right actor.
The guy with the white hair.
The Donald Sutherland is the guy who was
in a invasion of the body snatchers,
maybe 80 to the same guy he did.
He just did the hunger games movies.
He was like the,
the president and the hunger games.
That's the guy,
right?
With Helen Mirren?
Yeah.
That guy.
He does a ton.
Whenever I think of him,
I think of invasion of the body.
Then when he became one of the guys and
uh,
you know,
who's getting paid?
I'm the guy who does the allstate,
you know,
there's another one that I could have
done that guy.
I could have Dennis Haysburt.
I could have done that for a lot less.
He knows his name.
A friend of mine used to work with him
on a series.
That's why I know his name,
but you can go to any mall in America
and he was also a real estate guy.
He was also in major league pitchers.
Toronto.
That's.
Yeah,
he was Toronto and Major League jumbo.
I don't remember that at all.
I barely remember major league.
Major League.
Oh yeah,
that's him.
Major League.
I love that movie.
That's how.
That was a fun fucking movie that.
That's one of those movies that if
you're flicking channels and it's on.
I'm watching.
Yeah.
Charlie Sheen back before the crack.
Yep.
Wesley snipes.
When he was paying taxes on the second
one,
I tried to act like it wasn't.
Omar epps played the same character in
the second month.
Really?
They replace Wesley Wesley on a bunch of
issues.
There was a great patent.
Oswald bet he does about being in blade
two and about how they replaced Wesley
snipes halfway in the movie.
Like it's western,
I don't know,
allegedly was,
was fucking around with coke or
something and just was completely off
his rocker,
you know,
it was a weird time for him.
I've got a friend who grew up with them.
Yeah,
I mean literally like Wesley was
sleeping on his couch when he got his
first American Express commercial.
His first acting job.
Yeah.
And uh,
and then he got,
I forgot what movie,
He did some movie,
I think it was a fight movie or
something like that.
And he kind of disappeared.
And my buddy's wife,
she's always like,
you better never.
Wesley snipes us.
Oh,
you better not disappeared.
You first movie commercial for Western
Union.
It was good that commercials commercial
money was always a big thing.
Right.
Then you got,
if you've got a national commercial back
then you got paid back.
That up here.
Went to the scene where the pipe was
going off.
God Damn
hilarious.
Look at the computer guy.
Look at the computer back then.
So western union,
while punching numbers into a terminal,
got to get that bail money.
So that's our lifetime in our lifetime.
Things have changed so radically.
Just stop and think about 30 years
before that it wasn't much different.
It was a little different but not like
it.
It is now.
When you think about parents' lifetimes.
Yeah,
exactly.
To go from radio.
Have lived from radio to the Internet.
Not that my mom will mess with the end
of that and mom doesn't fuck with him.
We tried her church,
started doing the bulletins online.
So we gave her a smartphone like a few
years ago.
I gave her one of those.
Um,
what do they call it?
The cricket phone.
Oh yeah.
Where it has like four numbers on it and
that's all you do.
And well they made a smartphone version.
It literally has one button that says
email the button,
it says text button that says pictures
at a button that says call.
And it's like,
mom,
I can't like,
this is the simplest we could do.
She wouldn't do it.
She won't mess with it.
Wow.
Bad for a long time.
You know,
my mom was still like,
talk fast as long distance,
you know.
It was like,
don't worry mom,
I got this.
I got long distance.
Money ain't rich,
but I got long distance money.
That's right.
Remember when,
remember when roaming,
where you would drive your car an hour
outside of where your coverage area was.
She'd be fucked if you got a t and t you
still got Romeo,
man a t and t they used to just raped me
when I traveled.
It was ridiculous.
Really?
Oh,
and then forget what,
like when you went to the festival in
Montreal,
it's like,
listen,
I'm gonna need my pay plus m a t and t
money might make a call one call.
Yeah.
I know a lot of dudes or use their phone
overseas and didn't know when they got a
thousand dollars bill and got back home
like a thousand dollars per phone call.
And the one guy he did,
he used his data.
He kept using his phone.
He had a $3,000.
Bill when he came back from Montreal is
data was on 24 slash seven for like
eight days.
It's how can they charge you that much?
That's just rude.
They cut it in half or something like
that,
but it was still.
Yeah,
they give you a break.
Unreal.
So sweet of them.
Yeah,
but it's interesting that competition is
sort of erase that whole roaming thing
like because more people were jockeying
for a share of the market rises and t,
t mobile,
all these different people and players
and sprint and they just had to make
some concessions for competition.
Well the next big test is going to be a
thousand dollars iphone,
right?
Because if people pay it,
then that's what phones are going to
cost.
Well isn't that new Samsung Galaxy note
eight?
Isn't that similarly priced?
They're both going to be up there.
Yeah,
they're basically computers.
That note eight is pretty fucking sweet,
man.
They're bad ass,
but that's a.
that's a big jump.
That's basically you're doubling the
price of a cell phone,
is it?
You know,
what are the new ones now?
I think new ones now are five to 600
bucks.
I didn't just buy it,
but that's the point,
but now you're not going to get that,
you know,
because it's always been.
You get the discount if they sign up for
two years or so that,
well apparently with this one it's going
to be just you gotta just by the phone.
They're just kinda getting greedy.
Yeah.
So it's.
I think it's a test because if people
don't go for it then they'll be like,
oh,
well we got to go back to the old model
and uh,
will be willing to pay more money for a
phone if you knew that the phone was
made by people that got paid a living
wage.
Yeah,
I would.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm all about that man.
I'm fine with paying more for something
to take care of the employees.
That's the
best argument for made in America.
You know,
that made in America argument is like,
some people look at it as patriotism or
nationalism and I could see that,
but there's also the argument of it's
made in America.
Then people have to get paid,
you know,
like at least a minimum wage.
Know,
you know,
who said it and it,
and it's been lost and I think it's one
of his great quote,
Henry Ford,
to never forget,
you have to pay them enough to buy the
cars.
Uh,
that's a smart quote.
And they forgot.
Henry Ford was a wizard.
Yeah.
Henry Ford also figured out that you can
make fenders out of hemp and have far
superior to metal.
Yeah.
There's an old video.
You're seeing those old video of his
first car.
No.
His first car that he made had fenders
made out of hemp and he's banging it
with a hammer and the hammer is just bow
hemp is.
Forget about whatever anybody feels
about marijuana and stoners are always
trying to push it on us.
Just hemp itself as a textile,
as a,
as a commodity hemp when they use him to
make things out of hemp is a very
strange.
Where if you had a piece of hemp,
like the size of this water bottle is a
large water bottle.
Right?
Have you had a piece of hemp that was
that thick?
It would be hard like oak,
but light,
like Balsa Wood.
It's fucking weird.
Similar to bamboo or it's similar to
bamboo,
but stronger.
Much stronger.
It's a very,
very strange.
It's the impact is 10 times stronger
than steel.
Hemp plastic panels.
Now you go see if he can find the video.
It's a crazy video because in the video
he's banging on this fucking fender with
a hammer.
Crazy video because he had my phone to
make videos in 1910.
It probably had a dude,
a truck.
One of those things.
They probably had to crank it back then,
right Craig?
Yeah.
He probably did like,
that's his car actually.
Pretty Dope car.
If you had that today,
drive around that bitch with everybody.
No,
look at this.
He's wailing on it with a fucking
heroin.
It just bounces off and it's completely
sustainable.
You can plant it in an area and
regenerate it within a year.
Whereas if you have the same issue with
trees and you try to regenerate an area
with trees,
it takes decades.
So is it?
Well,
I guess so it'd be more similar to
bamboo than fiberglass.
Yes.
More similar to bamboo than fiberglass,
but superior to both of those things.
It's fucking amazing.
It's fiberglass cracks and breaks the
light like fiberglass,
but far stronger.
I had a,
uh,
had a corvette that defender just
cracked and broke off.
Oh,
I have a corvette.
I have an older one.
Got a magnificent more.
Yeah.
They,
um,
who made a car recently out of hemp,
Lotus.
Lotus made a hemp car really recently
and you know,
people were hoping that,
uh,
other manufacturers are gonna start
using this because it's actually safer.
It's stronger than fiberglass.
Safer than fiberglass.
And it's like the similar in terms of
its weight,
that stripe down the middle is exposed.
There's photos where you could see it
more clearly.
Jamie cv like just.
Yeah,
there it is.
So that,
that is what the actual fiber looks like
where it's not painted and,
and,
um,
sealed or it's just sealed rather,
but not a colored.
So you could see the fiber.
It's,
it's incredible stuff,
man.
And it doesn't fuck with the
environment.
It's actually good.
It's a cleaner process.
So why is it not being used?
Because it's connected to marijuana,
it's the only reason just publishing
publicity.
Up until very recently,
hemp was illegal to grow in the United
States.
Now I know this for a fact because my
company on it,
we had to buy all of our hemp from
Canada when we sell hemp protein,
which is one of the best versions of
protein that you can get in plant based
forum because it has a full amino acid
profile,
very easy to digest.
If you get high quality hemp hearts like
the stuff that we sell real easy going
down like it doesn't fuck with you or
give you a gas.
Like some people have issues with like
whey protein if they have any sort of a
lactose intolerance and some people just
doesn't.
Doesn't agree with them.
Hemp is very easy to digest.
I mean I'd take it hemp protein shake
and I'll go to the gym like an hour
later and have no issues working out
pretty hard.
Whereas some stuff,
just see how I fucked up.
I fucked up eating.
But because of all the laws that have
been in existence since the 19 thirties
regarding hemp and marijuana,
that's one thing that a lot of people
don't even realize that the laws were
actually put in place to stop hemp as a,
as a commodity,
not really to stop marijuana.
They stopped marijuana to stop him.
I mean it was all done by William
Randolph hearst.
But this fucking asshole in the 19
thirties ruined things in 2017 with
propaganda that even the term marijuana
was never used.
Marijuana was a wild Mexican tobacco.
The reason why they used the term
marijuana because they could,
instead of saying cannabis,
which everybody already knew.
Instead of saying hemp,
They said,
well,
there's this drug called marijuana and
these Mexicans and blacks are smoking is
drunk and,
and all the white women.
Oh yeah.
And the 13,
that documentary,
they talked about it fucking amazing.
Anything that with opium and the Chinese
from the railroads,
you know,
that to this day is why hamp is such a
problem in this country.
All that bullshit from 1930 something is
why we're still.
We still have issues about hemp protein.
Do you get high off of it?
Anything?
It doesn't.
It's no thc whatsoever.
It's just the fiber from the stocks.
It's curious to me personally.
I'm going to try it.
Yeah.
Oh,
hemp protein is amazing,
you know,
but I do.
You have to tell you the CBDS,
which,
uh,
you know,
a really great for pain and pain
medication or pain,
inflammation and things along those
lines.
Some people,
like Greg Fitzsimmons says he gets high
off off of
it.
I don't understand that.
He said he tries that,
a Charlotte's web cbd oil,
which is full profile hemp oil.
He says it gives them hi b might be
crazy.
It's fits.
Who knows?
He's a,
he's a city boy.
Things react per lead is metabolism.
But if we were,
if we were reasonable and intelligent,
we'd be making a shitload of things with
hemp.
Fiber is so easy to regenerate,
so easy to grow.
It's totally sustainable.
It's healthy.
Maybe that will,
uh,
maybe that will change.
I'm hoping maybe that will change in
time.
We're slowly,
slowly waking up and getting rid of
those.
Um,
well,
like you said,
the propaganda that created it.
You know what another thing is that
people make plastic with it.
You can make degradable biodegradable
hemp plastic.
Well,
you're going to weed.
I mean,
you know,
people do.
We've had legal weed,
right?
People aren't running the streets
raping.
I am for.
Well you might've been.
I just smoke pot.
I know who I am.
I wake up,
I'll wake up covered in blood and is an
argument that it wasn't the wheat.
Yeah,
that's the idea that,
you know,
this is the one that's illegal.
It's so fucking crazy when you can just
go to a liquor store or just,
you know,
go to a bar almost anywhere they look
and that.
And that's the lobby.
I read this crazy article about the weed
thing in Vegas,
like they made a compromise with the
liquor lobby that you had to have a
liquor distributor license to distribute
the marijuana to literally take it to
the dispensary's and no one got the
license so they couldn't deliver it for.
I mean I'm sure they figured it out,
but initially like nobody could
deliberate the liquor company.
He was like,
well,
why would we deliver it like we don't
want to,
you know,
we want you to drink.
Well,
they were running into a shortage.
It was so chaotic when the first.
Because they couldn't,
couldn't distributed anywhere.
It was crazy.
Well,
they couldn't keep up with the demand
either.
It was just so insane.
Oh,
no doubt.
No doubt.
And,
and they still have the money issue,
right?
They still have the issue of,
uh,
the risk of putting into banks,
especially with sessions.
Yeah.
Sessions wanting to be some anti weed
guy.
Little goofy.
Alf.
One weird fucker.
That guy is,
you know,
it's just.
I like watching trump shit on him,
see him,
just sort of have to swallow it and eat
it.
You know,
in the beginning he was a.
trump was real high on him and in any
wouldn't recruit recluse himself because
of the investigation in Russia.
My favorite joke was when Roy Wood Jr
called sessions a confederate monument.
That's a great job.
Yeah.
He's,
he was a guy that was,
it was Ted Kennedy that was calling him
a disgrace.
Like back in the 19 eighties.
Oh,
this guy was,
he was too racist to be a judge in the
Reagan era,
you know,
and,
and I mean literally like Congress was
like,
no,
like you're too,
you're too far gone.
And he had,
this guy has a long history of crazy,
you know,
when he wants to bring back the just say
no days literally said that he wants to
bring back the policy of just saying no.
And the war on drugs,
the war on drugs,
throwing people in jail forever,
just saying no.
And he's still living in the Nancy
Reagan days.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
That was probably progressive for him.
You know what I mean?
That was,
that was a lot.
Yeah,
he's moved away from the far right.
He's one of those guys that like,
he wants it to be 1950.
Yeah,
that's his,
that's his dream.
He was in high school back then,
getting all the ladies know things were
good and he wants you to be 1950.
That there were black people were
segregated.
There were no Mexicans,
like Mexican didn't need.
It.
Didn't even exist in the 1950.
[inaudible] Ricardo was the only Latino
in America and the jets and the jets in
west side story.
It was crazy.
And Ricky Ricardo though was Cuban.
Cubans were completely respectable.
Yeah.
It was like a man from Spain,
like a man from Spain.
I come on over to America would be a
Spanish gentleman.
Right.
You know,
it's like there's a difference.
When people started looking at Mexicans,
it was,
it became this different thing.
Cuba.
Cuba was Vegas.
Yeah.
It was big as my dad was around in that
era when Cuba was where you went to a
vacation and gambling at all.
Yeah.
I must have been weird times,
Huh?
Yeah.
That had to be crazy,
but they still have the cars from back
then and they keep them running with
anything.
Anything that,
you know,
you talk about engineers like can you
imagine if today you still had to keep
it 1953 chevy running with like,
you know what I'm like,
Oh,
you might think you're creative,
but here's a 1953 Chevy,
half of a boat engine and a lawn mower
like this.
This is literally the professor from
Gilligan's island where you just like
you,
you just make shit work.
Remember that show?
They remember macgyver.
They don't remember.
The professor from Gilligan's island was
the original Makoto professor used to
make machines out of bananas and Palm
Show today.
Everybody will be fucking.
Nobody fucked up then.
Nothing ever happened on TV.
Ginger would just always have makeup on
it for everybody.
She had heels and a dress on,
on this.
Smart people.
Look at Marianne.
I want Marianne's the move.
That's the move.
He want her.
She's like low key.
She's probably freaking bad,
but it's just like she was probably
banging Gilligan.
You think so?
Yeah.
In real life or could.
No,
you pick up the professor and the
skipper.
We're fighting over ginger all the time.
Right?
Then the hollows had each other.
So Maryann,
she just,
you know,
slip in and out on Gilligan.
What about skipper?
That port?
Fuck.
Skip bridges.
Bizarre attacks in Havana.
Hit us by networking Cuba.
What does that.
I typed in this.
I was looking at recent news,
and this is coming out like yesterday,
attack acts
and US personnel and Havana.
What is this?
What's happening to them?
Spies posted to the embassy under
diplomatic cover reported hearing.
Bizarre sounds experiencing.
Oh,
this was a audio attacks,
right?
The there were hitting them with sound.
Oh Shit.
Sorry.
That happened.
I'm experiencing even stranger physical
effects.
The United States realized something was
wrong.
Individuals familiar with the situation
said,
yeah,
they were using some sonic weapon
started within days of President Donald
Trump's surprise election in November.
Surprise election.
Okay.
The precise timeline or remains unclear,
including whether intelligent officer
intelligence officers with the first
victims hit or merely the first victims
to report it,
us has called the situation ongoing.
To date,
the Trumpet Administration largely has
described the 21 victims.
Wow.
At
the US embassy personnel or members of
the diplomatic community.
That description suggested only bonafide
diplomats in their family members were
struck with no logical motivation beyond
disrupting us Cuban relations.
Yeah.
It was some sort of seemed to not even
describing what kind of attack it is.
Some kind of scroll down here.
The first disturbing reports of piercing
high pitch noises and inexplicably
ailments pointed to someone deliberately
targeting the US government intelligence
network on the communist run island and
what seems like a bone chilling
escalation of the tit for tat spy games
the Washington van have waged over the
last half century.
Know there's an end for me.
New Year's.
Interesting.
Have you ever heard of the Brown note?
What's that?
I was thought that maybe it was getting
at this,
but I don't even know if it's actually
real,
but it sounds like it's real.
It's a sonic note that can be used
supposedly weaponized to make someone
and shit themselves.
Oh,
I did hear about that and I know when I
was an audio school,
I remember we were asking the teacher if
you're going to,
if that's that a possibility or whatnot,
and I don't know if we ever got anywhere
realistic because it tested well.
I'm glad to hear it.
Oh,
because a human hearing stops at 20
hertz,
which is a really low base and you can
barely do.
You have to have really good hearing and
here that if you do a sound test,
someone will play that sound and it'll
almost does sound like a pressure.
You'll feel like a pressure change in
your head.
I have a friend who's ears are fucked
up.
My friend John Dudley,
you know John Dudley,
his ears are fucked up from guns.
Like you shut a lot of guns and he was
younger and he blew blues hearing out.
But so he has a hard time hearing
certain things but he can hear really
deep sounds way better than I can.
My hearing is good,
but he,
he's got like,
it's almost like,
you know,
when someone is blind they can hear
better.
It's almost like that.
Like his,
his hearing is fucked up,
but certain notes penetrate that don't
get me.
I think he can hear like,
like deep sounds like an animal grumping
like,
and he's like,
you hear that?
I'm like,
no.
Anything like you can hear shit that
most people can hear.
It's weird.
It's very weird because most of his
sound is fucked up.
So he just.
Is that Brown note real?
That's why I was asking if you had ever
heard of it or have heard of it.
That would be.
That would be your best and worst
podcast over the brown note.
Mcast driving their cars just shitting
themselves on the train.
Shit themselves.
Amazing,
but I hate it.
Yeah.
Imagine he played in the background of
the most amazing podcasts ever.
Like you have some really cool person in
here.
Really interesting subject.
I remember mythbusters tried to do this
and I think they used a really,
really big sound system to try to
recreate this low frequency stuff.
Almost impossible to get and I think
they didn't get very far because they
don't have that government shit bro.
Stuff.
They use it in Cuba.
Maybe that's what's
going on.
Those people shitting themselves,
they just don't want to say it.
That's what I did.
I was hoping it would say something like
that.
Yeah.
I wonder what the sonic attack is like.
Do they pointed out you?
You can have that.
I know for sure.
The speakers that can be taken literally
pointed at you like across the street
and press a button.
It's the sounds going right out and
fucking with your inherent.
Yeah.
Will sound it's directional.
So that absolutely makes sense.
Yeah.
How weird is that?
That they're doing?
Who's doing that?
Must be someone in the Cuban government.
Doesn't want us over there.
It was just to fuck with the uh,
just to fuck with the diplomat.
The Yankee spies.
They said that is something that's
always going on.
And just little games they play with
each other.
Yeah.
This says they couldn't even get in here
where they couldn't even hear him.
They just weren't.
And they weren't even aware of an attack
does later they had symptoms.
Oh Wow.
Probably a little bit headache,
I would imagine.
Yeah.
How the boy magic that gets into the
wrong hands.
What if that becomes like a,
you know,
technology gets into the hands of
regular people eventually like tasers
and shake.
You just go by a Taser or had you get by
some sound shit and just pointed at your
neighbor while he's mowing the lawn.
Art Give me know if the MP is an emp,
a real threat to America or whatever.
Like a matrix style,
emp wipes out all of the electronics
area with it as a natural solar blasts,
any sort of solar flare.
I mean there's,
there's,
there's a massive potential for solar
interrupt and interruption of our entire
power grid,
like some massive solar flare happens
and just cooks all of our satellites.
The entire power grid.
We have to start from scratch.
We're down.
No power.
The emp.
Whoa.
We're in Puerto Rico.
BNP is real,
but I think you have to create so much
power to have one that big.
I think that's,
that's the limiting
factor on it.
I had a guy in here,
Peter Schiff was here.
What does this day,
this son brought darkness back.
There was a blackout caused by solar
flare.
There was in the nineties,
89.
Oh,
okay.
The entire province of Quebec,
Canada suffered an electrical power
blackout.
Hundreds of blackouts occurred and some
parts of North America every year they
go back back out was different because
this one was caused by a solar storm.
Yeah.
Apparently like what we're,
what we've tracked so far in terms of
solar activity is just a tiny fraction
of what the sun is capable of and the
sun is capable of some pretty wild
variations and if those wild variations,
if it hits like a real odd end,
it could just fuck her entire system
though.
Well,
we're at the mercy of nature always,
you know,
no matter how big our egos get over our
creations,
what we build,
nature's like a,
you know,
a wipe that shit out in a minute.
You know what I mean?
Like there's no.
I used to do a joke about that.
Like oh look at my beach house.
She tells us I stayed at one for awhile
and at nighttime it reveals itself in
the daytime.
It looks.
Look at all that
beautiful blue water.
It's amazing.
So pretty the ocean at night it is a
black munster space.
It's a dark monster because you don't
see anything and you realize like,
oh,
that is fucking quadrillions of gallons
of water.
That could just swallow up the entire
city.
Tons of weight and pressure,
you know,
like snow,
snow is the same way,
you know,
just shut everything down.
Just a major snowfall,
but you don't live next to snow.
That's the fucked up thing about living
next to the ocean as a.
you're literally on the edge,
but you can live in one of those places
that gets hit with,
you know,
10 feet of snow,
12 feet of snow and you're screwed.
Yeah.
But you could see that shit coming and
get out of dodge,
but we don't know.
It's crazy because the rich people live
on the edge.
That's the same thing with earthquakes.
I told my mom a long time ago like she'd
be,
are you okay?
I said,
mom,
let's hope one day I make enough money
to live somewhere I have to worry about,
you know,
fires or you know what I mean?
Like I live in the valley.
I'm fine.
Like I wish I wish I had to worry about
fires,
but you keep water,
snow brush clearing a little bit.
Now I don't have a full kit.
I have a Red Cross kit and a couple of
gallons of water.
But um,
I'm gonna I'm gonna expand on that.
I have some food,
some freeze dried food.
You know,
a guy who went through Katrina told me
cash,
cash.
He said keep cash in the house.
He said after Katrina milk was $100 a
gallon.
100.
Uh,
well yeah.
He said you got to keep a large sum of
cash in the house as part of your
disaster kit.
Something I never would have thought.
But you said,
yeah,
there's a disaster.
The price of everything goes up and cash
is the only currency.
Like you can't use credit cards if
there's no electricity.
Wasn't there an issue in Houston where
people are getting arrested for price
gouging on water and yeah,
they were charging.
I don't know.
What was it?
90 bucks a case I think for water and
$100 a gallon for gas or something.
It's human nature.
What are you going to do with us?
I wish we can wrap this up on a nice
note,
but I gotta I gotta end this.
Alright.
Anything good to say to people?
Uh,
yeah,
yeah.
Be Be Nice to be nice to people.
You know what bothers.
No,
seriously.
This is a little thing,
but you know what bothers me.
Don't.
If you're in the elevated throw,
hit the door.
Close button.
Yeah,
button.
It's just an asshole.
There's no time that door closed.
That's an asshole.
Move.
People like it though.
They like to press that button to see
someone almost held there,
but hold on.
Oh,
you went away that.
That's how I'm.
That's how I'm changing the world,
Joe.
That's how I'm cheap.
Listen,
I can't solve gun violence.
I can't.
I can't help with the football protests
or anything,
but if you can just not press the door
close button.
It's a start.
But there are some dumb motherfuckers
with like four kids when the elevator's
completely packed,
like hold the door,
hold the door.
Like where are you going?
No,
you are you going?
Where are you going?
And if your kid presses every button on
the elevator and he accidentally takes
one to the head,
we can't be held responsible.
See?
See,
I'm not saying that he's had his elbow
height.
We're just moving that saying that got
in the way of just saying,
stay away from the door closed,
but don't.
Plus that door.
Close button.
Nice gentlemen.
That's a strong advice from Alonzo
Bowden.
It's the wings of a butterfly and
eventually become a hurricane.
You letting someone in that elevator
might change the course of history.
Think about it.
It's like when Peter Parker left,
that burglar passed by and it killed his
uncle Ben.
Boom.
Then the tournament of Spiderman.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Alright.
Strong words.
I like it.
Both ladies.
Gentlemen begs.
Thank you brother.